networking is the practice of connecting
two or more computers or devices to
enable communication and information
sharing this connection can be
established through various means such
as wired or wireless connections it can
serve multiple purpose including sharing
resources communicating with other users
accessing the internet and many more
devices are connected using network
protocols such as ethernet and Wi-Fi and
are assigned using IP addresses that
allow them to communicate with each
other networking is an essential
component of modern Computing and is
used in various settings from small
businesses to large corporations and
from home networks to Global networks
networking is a rapidly growing field
with many career opportunities available
as technology advances the need for
skill networking professionals is
increasing some of the most popular
networking career opportunities include
network engineer network administrator
Network security specialist wireless
network engineer Cloud network engineer
and many more according to Blaster a
network engineer's average salary in the
United States is around 81 000 in India
it is 5 lakhs per annum
the help of our Celtic cyber security
boot camp you can launch your career as
a cyber security specialist and acquire
the knowledge and expertise businesses
need to safeguard sensitive data and
vital systems from cyber attacks with
that in mind Hey guys welcome to the
networking full course video by simply
learn this video will begin with the
basics of networking for beginners
followed by ethernet we will learn about
types of networks next we will move on
to topics like Network topology IP
address osm model and TCP IP protocol
finally we will cover the topics like
network security farewall network
routing using digital's algorithm and
error deduction then we will dive into
little Advanced topics like stop and
weight protocol sliding window protocol
go back in arq protocol and selective
repeat erq and cover Dynamic cost
configuration protocol we will conclude
this networking full course by
discussing the essential interview
question and answers of networking to
help every individual crack an interview
so let's get started with the two major
types of network that should be
considered basic knowledge for someone
starting out with networking lands and
rents the first variety of networks is a
local area network also known as Lang it
comprises of cables gateways switches
routers and additional parts that allow
these devices to connect to private
servers cloud services and other lands
via larger Networks the growth of
virtualization has also sped up the
creation of virtual lands which let
Network managers divide and logically
organize Network nodes without having to
make significant modifications to the
infrastructure
the computers in each department could
be conceptually linked to the same
switch in an office with many
departments be it accountancy it support
and administration
still they might be segregated to
operate separately the benefits of a lan
are similar to those of any collection
of connected devices they may access
anywhere control one another exchange
files print to Shared printers and
utilize a single internal connection
to better understand this logic let us
take a sample structure
you can see the various components of a
local network connection in this picture
and now we can see three different
devices a system a laptop and a printer
so you have these few devices that need
to be connected to a single local Ada
Network
now to identify these devices inside the
network we need to assign an identifier
to each device so this is where an IP
address can help
an IP address is a language string of
digits allocated to any device connected
to a network that utilizes Internet
Protocol as the communication medium is
the digital equivalent of your house or
workplaces mailing address
the addresses are divided into four
sections separated by drops each
traditional tree strain numeral portion
represents an 8-bit binary integer which
can range from 0 to 255. these four
integers are expressed in normal decimal
notation and then separated by Docs
however computers work with binary
numbers meaning zeros and ones and each
number in an ipv4 address represents an
8-bit binary integer which is why none
of them can be more than 255.
the distribution of this IP addresses is
not just limited to land every device
which is a part of the network will have
its own IP address as assigned by the
network administrator as seen in the
picture we can now identify each device
individually by the designated IP
addresses
now the primary purpose of a network
being the ability of multiple devices to
communicate and exchange information
with each other this IP addresses serve
only half the purpose since allotment
and identification of these addresses
need to be managed automatically and On
Demand if the laptop shown on the left
of the screen wants to use the printer
in the network it needs to know which
particular device or more precisely
which particular IP address to
communicate
this is where a switch comes into play
it takes a role of the delegation and
commands in a particular Network
let's learn more about switches in
detail
a network switch joints devices in a
network such as computers printers
wireless access funds and allows them to
communicate with each other by
exchanging data packets they can do both
physical Hardware devices that handle
real networks or software-based virtual
devices
the vast majority of network equipment
in modern data networks are switches
will index the PCS access points
automated equipment and some iot devices
via wired connections such as card entry
systems
the LinkedIn computers and data centers
that run virtual machines or VMS as well
as the actual server and most of the
storage equipment
based on the type of switches employed
they can either differentiate between
network devices using either their IP
addresses or Mac addresses which are
separate types of addresses allotted to
each Hardware device irrespective of the
network it is connected to
now that you understand the major parts
of a local area network a major query
that may come to your mind is how can
these local networks can communicate
with other networks a rocker is employed
at the Forefront of every network setup
to facilitate communication between
foreign Networks
this router can then be used to connect
to the Internet so we can communicate
with the loved ones from the comfort of
our own homes
so let's learn a little more about
routers
the router is a physical or virtualized
Internet working equipment that receives
analyzes and transmits data packets
across computer networks the router
checks and data packets destination IP
address and utilizes headers and
forwarding tables to determine the best
path to transform the packet
consider the router to be an air traffic
controller and data package should be
airplanes flying to various airports or
networks and space
each package like each chat has a unique
destination and must be steered to its
destination as effectively as possible
a router helps direct these data packets
to the intended IP addresses in the same
manner that the air traffic controller
ensures that flights arrive at their
destination without getting loss while
experiencing severe disruptions
router employs an internal routing table
which is a collection of Pathways to
multiple Network destinations to
properly direct packets it scans the
header of a packet to establish its
destination then consults a routing
table to find the most efficient way to
their destination
the packet is subsequently sent to the
next Network along the Route
a router also has an IP address which is
often called as the network Gateway
a crucial part of the networking setup
is determining whether a particular
piece of Hardware is a part of a local
network or a foreign device
as you already know specific IP
addresses exist for each device in a
network be it a local or wide area
network all these IP addresses must
belong to a particular range of
addresses which are often known as the
subnet or sub Network and it's helped
return on the overall range of a local
area network
for example the IP addresses that can be
seen on the screen right now belong to a
subnet that is 255.255.0.0
the first of flags did not fix values
that must be present in every single IP
address of every single device in this
particular Network
in our case the 192.168 is the
consistent factor in every single IP
address shown on the screen
this implies that if the devices can
connect to a piece of equipment with an
IP address and it starts from 192.168
that device will most likely be in the
same local area network
the last two places are the three ranges
in this example which means they can be
any number less than 255 further helping
the router and switch differentiate
between multiple IP addresses in a
network
with that being said we can now take a
look at how wide area networks work
a wide area network or a van is in its
most basic form a collection of local
area networks or any other networks that
interact with one another
why Data Network is essentially a
network of networks with internet
serving as the world's biggest one
however when a router communicates with
devices outside a local network it tends
to mask the internally allocated IP
addresses and uses a single public IP
address for all the devices
this process is called Network address
translation or Nat IP allocation
a network address translation is a
method of translating one IP address to
another while these packets are in
transit through a router this improves
security and reduces the number of IP
addresses required by a company
answer how to receive some particular
information that must be transmitted to
a local device in the network it checks
the internal routing tables to determine
the correct internal IP address and the
current destination to send the external
leadership data too
but let's say a device on the external
network or a wide area network wants to
communicate directly with the device
from the local network
this cannot be allowed since this can be
a very big security risk for devices in
a secure environment
all of this M3 and exit rule creation
and handling can be taken care of by a
firewall
a firewall is a type of network security
device that analyzes the incoming and
outgoing networking traffic and allows
organized data packets depending on a
set of security rules
its objective is to provide a barrier
between your local network and external
traffic such as the internet
the most common sort of firewall which
are packed at filtering firewalls check
packets and prevent them from getting
through if they do not maintain
established security rules
this sort of firewall examines the
package destination and Source IP
addresses if the packet fits an allowed
rule on the firewall they are permitted
to access the network
but let's say we as users want to allow
external requests to reach individual
computers or devices on our local
network
there are two ways to facilitate this
Behavior the first way to go through
this step is by using a DMZ which stands
for a demilitarized zone
instead of communicating directly with
the local network device the external
data is sent to the router instead
the router will have created a DMZ sub
network with only those devices added to
it that require other external
information to reach them on altered
once the data is received by the router
it passes it on to the dng subnet and
subsequently to all the devices which
are a part of that summary
however since external data can reach
devices in a network without any
firewall checks if they are part of the
DMZ subnet the security risk associated
with this method are very large compared
to the second variant which is port
forward
ing is a method of granting external
devices access to computers on private
networks it accomplishes this by
translating an external IP address and
port to an internal IP address and port
all the devices talk to each other and
the network Gateway using the IP
addresses and specific ports for example
the TCP IP protocol basic internet usage
uses Port 80 on every Network
similarly we can create additional file
or rules to open up certain ports for
external devices to communicate with if
the designated ports are open during
communication the firewall will allow
the external network device or server to
communicate directly with the local
network device without any hindrance
so it's always really need to know for
now about the basics of networking
hope you learned something new today
what is ethernet
ethernet is a form of communication
Network that uses a wired medium to
connect devices for data Exchange in the
network for example LAN
also known as local area network
also van known as wide area network
ethernet also applies different protocol
on the data to be transmitted over the
communication Channel efficiently and
smoothly
moving on let's look into why to use
ethernet
as we now know the ethernet is a mode of
connection for multiple devices to share
and exchange data but using this way of
transmission also has its benefit
for example
the ethernet Network provides us with a
high speed connection for sharing data
ethernet also provides the user data
with a secure channel for transmission
the data that is transmitted over the
ethernet channel is reliable and has
rarely faced in issues at the sender
site
let's move on to the next heading
now we will look into different types of
ethernet
in general the ethernet is divided into
three different types
first is
the fast ethernet this type of ethernet
operates on a twisted pair cable
with the data transmission speed of up
to 100 Mbps
fast ethernet connections are used for
personal connections or use in companies
that require low internet connection
moving on we have gigabit Ethernet
this Linux is used for high-speed
internet connection
with the speed ranging from 1000 Mbps to
1 gbps
it is an upgraded form of fast ethernet
and the last type is switch ethernet
this ethernet type installs network
devices such as switches or hubs so as
to improve the network transmission
the transmission range for switched
ethernet connection is around 1000 Mbps
to 10 gbps
now let's look into the working of
ethernet
ethernet Services specifically work in
the first layer of the OSI model that is
known as the physical layer and the
second layer of the OSI model
also known as data link lab
functioning of the ethernet can be
divided into three different parts
First Step being
acquiring the physical address that is
Mac address media Access Control address
of the sender and the receiver device
then the second step is to check the
data security quality of the data and
the connection speed of the transmission
channel for efficient and smooth
transmission of data over the network
and the last step is to check Network
traffic and detect any error that occurs
in the communication Channel
to solve these issues if occur
csma protocols and other Protocols are
used
for example the csma protocol is used in
case of packet Collision in the network
channel
now let's look at a simple ethernet
model for further clarification of the
steps
but before we begin with the model
the point to be noted is
the transmission of data over the
ethernet channel is divided into two
parts
frames and packets
where packets represents a unit of data
in the network whereas frame refers to a
collection of data packets being
transmitted over the channel
and the application of ethernet Services
which includes security traffic check
and protocols being applied on the data
and that is when it reaches the receiver
end
moving on let's look into advantages and
disadvantages of using ethernet
for advantages we have cost of
installing ethernet connection is low in
comparison to other network channels
the security of the data being
transmitted over the ethernet channel is
maintained
as for disadvantages we have
it is suitable only for establishing
short distance communication Network due
to high requirement of Hardware
resources
whereas ethernet is also not suitable
for sharing real-time data and
information
let's look into some more advantages and
disadvantages
ethernet is suitable for maintaining the
data quality of the information being
transmitted
it also provides high-speed data
transmission option for the network
for disadvantages we have the network
traffic issue is a drawback of
installing ethernet cables
troubleshooting faults and issues in the
internet cable is also a Troublesome
work now let's move on to the last
heading for this topic that is ethernet
versus internet
the first difference is
connection medium
for ethernet connection physical cables
are required that means it uses wide
medium for connection
whereas in case of Internet it uses
Wireless mediums such as satellites
has a connection medium
moving on the next difference is
Network model
the ethernet is available only for a low
distance connection for example LAN
whereas internet is available for all
the network connection distances
beat Lan man or van
let's move on to the next difference
that is Network control
for ethernet
the complexity of the connection medium
is low due to the less distance it uses
and also provides much efficient
transmission of data over the
communication Channel whereas for
internet is a large collection of
networks and hence require large group
of administrator for control
the last difference between ethernet and
internet is
network security and reliability
ethernet connection is a secure network
from external interference and provides
data security
whereas in case of Internet it is an
open type of connection so it is more
prone to hacking attempts and less
secure network
with the first setting that is what is a
computer network
a computer network refers to a group of
networking devices for example computer
system switch router or hubs connected
to each other through our central unit
to share Hardware resources and
Information Services
the more to connect different devices in
a computer network can be based on wired
or Wireless medium which depends upon
the requirement of the user
and the availability of network channels
now let's move forward with the next
setting that is different types of
computer networks available in a network
channel
thank you
there are different types of computer
networks available to choose from which
also depends upon the need of the user
or the network channel
on this basis we can differentiate into
four different types where the first is
personal area network that is pan Which
as the name suggests is used in personal
area to connect devices like mobile
phones personal computers etc
the next type of network is local area
network also known as LAN
this area network is used to connect
multiple devices across different
buildings on multiple devices in a
single building
and the next computer network is
metropolitan area network also known as
man which connects multiple land
networks within it
as for the last Network we have wide
area network also known as van which
covers locations that are not easily
available through wired medium for
example different parts of states are
connected to each other using wide area
network in this session we will look
into local area network metropolitan
area network and wide area network
let's move forward with the first that
is local area network
the local area network or Lan is used to
connect devices that are available
in a limited range
or small geographical location
as it does not cover large locations
because of Hardware limitation
the devices that are connected in this
computer Channel use multiple protocols
for proper and efficient exchange of
data and internet services
the data exchange occurs from a server
device that acts as a central unit and
is passed on to the devices that are
connected in the network channel
let's take a look at some of the
features of local area network
the data transmitted
in the network that is Land network is
relatively higher in comparison to other
network types man and man
because it covers a small geographical
distance
so the speed of data transmission is
very high
land uses private Network addresses for
network connectivity
as the exchange of data and services
takes place in a closely lit Channel
which decreases the error occurring rate
and also provides much better security
let's take a look at some of the
advantages and disadvantages of applying
Lan Network
for advantages we have
it has a single control unit
which is used to store data
and information and can be used anytime
transferring of data information becomes
much easier and much faster in line
Networks
as for disadvantages we have
data security is compromised if the Lan
admin decides to steal data and
information
as for the other disadvantages
it requires constant Administration for
continuing data services and
distributing Hardware resources in Align
Network
with this we have completed the Lan
Network part let's move on to the next
that is man network
the metropolitan area network or man is
a network type that encompasses network
connection of an entire city or
connection of a small area in a country
the area covered is less in comparison
to van and faces moderate Network
traffic due to the large location it
covers
the exchange of data occurs from one
line Network to the other Lan Network
and this case
is looped
let's take a look at some of the
features for metropolitan area network
the metropolitan area network covers a
large geographical area and is also used
as an internet service provider by many
of the local services
because it provides High data
transmission rate
it also applies many network devices for
smooth data services and is connected
through telephone lines using wired
medium to provide High internet services
let's move on to the advantages and
disadvantages of using man
it applies fiber optic cable for high
transmission and much better security in
comparison to Lan Network
it also uses full duplex method for data
transmission that is data exchange
occurs simultaneously
as for disadvantages we have
it needs a good quality Hardware
resources and the cost of installation
is very high
it also needs an experienced technician
to maintain
and provide much efficient data services
in case of man network
now let's move on to the next setting
that is Van Network
the wide area network of van is designed
to connect devices over large distances
like a Global Network that is the
internet
because the wide area network covers a
very large geographical area
for example connection between different
states
or even between countries
it uses Wireless Medium as a connection
mode for example Network tasks and
satellites
it also can be termed as the connection
of multiple lands or multiple mans
let's take a look at some of the
features of wide area network
wide area network uses satellite Medium
as we already saw
the satellite medium is used to connect
multiple Network tasks which in turns
provide high-speed data connection for
the devices in a network channel
whereas the data transmission rate of a
wide area network is in comparison to
Lan and man very low because it uses
Wireless medium in most of the cases
so the speed of data transmission is low
and it also covers a larger distance so
it often faces
data errors and loss of information
now let's take a look at the advantages
and disadvantages outline one network
when Network uses multiple Network tasks
to connect numerous devices
to be interconnected with the internet
it also covers a very large area to
establish multiple connection between
different parts of a country
and also connect different countries as
well
let's take a look at the disadvantages
of applying van Network
the chances of an error occurring in a
van network is very high due to the
availability of different types of
network channels network devices and
different modes of connection medium
the initial cost of setting up a van
network is very high as it needs very
experienced technician to work on
and requires Hardware resources example
satellites Network tasks which are very
costly to set up let's begin with the
first heading what is Network topology
it is referred to as an arrangement a
multiple system and network devices
interconnected to each other
through a physical medium or logical
channels
the term Network topology is combination
of two individual Network concept
first is the network part which
represents the devices or systems that
are also known as nodes
which is connected and how to change the
data within the network then the other
part is topology which represents the
connection medium between different
network devices and governs the data
flow between them moving on let's talk
about why do we apply the concept of
network topology for the first point it
allows the users to understand the
overall model of the network along with
the number of devices installed and
their positions in the network which
provide ease of installation of security
measures and network and helps in case
of troubleshooting cases then for the
next reason applying Network topology
helps the user to understand the
communication relationship among the
different devices and through a
connection medium
this in turn helps the network
professionals to set up an optimal
Network unit for the user
next in the list we have different types
of topologies used in networking
first is the bus topology then we have
ring topology Then star topology then
tree topology and in the end mesh
topology but to understand the concept
of topology let's start by point to
point topology this is simpler form of
topology connection which consists of
two nodes connected through a connection
medium like a network cable
the nodes at the two ends of the cable
shares data information between them
where the data sharing part represents
the network and the cable connection is
the topology part
with this we have understanding of
network topology then let's begin with
complex types of tech connections first
is the bus topology in this topology the
connection channel is a single cable
known as the network backbone through
which all the other nodes are connected
to
in this network setting the data packets
sent by the nodes are provided with the
receiver address to avoid transmission
errors the data in this topology can
travel from any endpoint where they are
termed as terminate points advantages of
bus topology it is easy to set up due to
that simple configuration settings
this setting is also cost effective as
it requires only a network cable for the
connection
in the case of krishnor the whole
network remains unaffected as it does
not have any direct connection to the
other node let's take a look at
disadvantages of bus topology
in case of troubleshooting we require
the use of special equipment to detect
The Fault in the network in the case of
multiple data transmission the packet
Collision is the frequent occurrence
damaging the transmitted message data
due to the unavailability of network
devices such as switches repeaters Etc
the loss of data over long distances
communication is quite High
then ring topology as the name suggests
the node in the network are connected in
a circular pattern similar to a ring
the data transmitter in this connection
is always in the clockwise Direction
the topology does not have any
termination point due to its ring
structure the method of data
transmission is used is known as token
passing which involves sending a token
along with a data packet to which each
of the node matches to identify the
destination node using the destination
address in the token
next advantages of ring topology the
crash node can be easily removed from
the network
the configuration settings are not
complex for certain and materials are
easily accessible
the cost of installation is low as no
extra Network device are required to the
connection
moving on we have disadvantages of ring
topology in the case of a node crash the
whole system is affected and is known
accessible due to the direct connection
of each node the transfer of data is
slow due to the Token processing method
in the network
difficulty in The troubleshotting Fault
in the connection leads to the crash of
the whole network now let's talk about
start apology in this topology the
networks are connected to each other
through the central Hub which can be a
computer or a server the central unit in
the connection is also known as the
server and the nodes are known as the
clients any connection between the node
has to be through the server and is one
of the most popular topology connection
next advantages of start apology in case
of a node crash the network as a whole
remains unaffected as each node is
connected to the server of a connection
the hardware requirements are easily
available and of low cost
troubleshooting is easy
through the use of central Hub to
identify the faulty node disadvantages
in case of a server failure the whole
network is shut down as all nodes are
interconnected through the server the
connection configuration is complex due
to the pattern of the typology next up
free topology this topology is a
combination of tar and bus topology the
node Connection in the topology follows
hierarchical pattern with the topmost
node as a root and the branching node as
the child node the sharing of data is
from the root node to the child node
pattern
next up advantages of tree installation
of a new network group is easy due to
the root child configuration of the
network
in case of a node fault or trash the
whole network is not affected by the
error this makes it easier to
troubleshoot the issue
next up disadvantages in case of a
server crash in any of the star
connection group the whole network is
affected due to the complex setting of
The topology installing security points
is difficult in the network
configuring and troubleshooting internal
issues is quite complex due to this
topology next up match topology as the
name suggests this topology is a
connection of interconnected system
connected to each other in no particular
order
no installation of network devices such
as switch or hubs this topology pattern
can be divided into two forms first is
full match topology in this connection
all the nodes are connected to each
other in the network then we have
partial mesh topology where all of the
nodes are connected to each other
available in the network let's talk
about the advantages of mesh topology in
case of node damage the whole network
does not suffer from the fault due to
the interconnected patterns of the
connection the transmission of data is
very high in the network
next up disadvantages the cost of
installation is high due to the
requirement of multiple cables and nodes
for the network to function efficiently
the management of the network becomes
complex due to the large number of
interconnections in the network due to
the absence of repeater or a switch the
data signal loss during the transmission
is very high now let's take a look at
how to choose best topology for a
network configuration first of course
the installation cost is one of the
biggest factor that affects the type of
topology configuration we choose from
our Network as the cost of installing
cables routers such as and other network
connections is slow then we have easy
installation installing the hardware
devices efficiently and precisely is
also one of the factors that affect our
choice of network topology moving on we
have flexibility the ability of the
topology to include new network nodes
after installation and ease of
troubleshooting refers to the
flexibility of topology in the hand we
have reliable security it is important
that the Tuple installed allows us to
introduce proper security point in the
network and leading the fewer crash
cases by referring the above factors we
can decide the best topology of for our
Network assuming that a person had to
send a letter to a relative's house but
he wasn't sure which house though
so how can this problem exactly be
solved
well this problem can be solved if we
take a look at the house number
mentioned on the meal
let's take a look at the house number
on the meal it seems like the house
number is 2 that means the meal would go
to house number two
similarly we also have an identification
method on the internet that is known as
IP address which is used to identify
different mails and the owner of that
email address
let's now take a look at the agenda for
today's video
firstly we will know what is an IP
address then we'll see what functions
does IP address have moving on with
knowing different versions of IP
addresses and lastly different types of
IP address
firstly we'll understand what exactly is
an IP address
an IP address or Internet Protocol
address for an example is a unique
numerical identifier assigned to every
Network device when it connects to the
internet
this address is assigned by the internet
service provider which acts as a way for
the system to access the internet
applications and the unique identity for
the device
moving forward we will understand what
exactly are IP functions
to begin with IV functions can be
divided into two types for the first
function we have the internet service
provider assigns an IP address to the
network device the first function of the
address is to provide an identity to the
host on the internet whereas the second
identity is used as a location address
for the host on the internet
let's now take a look at different
versions of IP address
IP addresses can be divided into two
types where the first type is known as
ipv4 address whereas the other address
is known as IPv6
let's take a look at both of them in
detail
for first one we have ipb4 address
this is the original version of an IP
address developed on 32-bit binary
format which contains 2 to the power 32
address
the address range from 0 to 255 in terms
of zeros and ones
with four octets each of them separated
by a period the network device uses
binary format whereas the numerical
format is used for the host reference
the first part denotes the network part
in an IP address and the second part is
for the host part
now let's move on to the IPv6 address
type
with the rise in technology the ipv4
could not complete the requirements so
the need for ipv4 arrows based on 128
bit address size which is sufficient for
a long time which is approximately
320 undecilion
this type of IPv6 address is designed
for four hexadecimal digits and 8 sets
with each block containing 16 bits
separated by a colon
now let's take a look at the IP classes
IP classes are designed for the purpose
of EC assignment of addresses to the
network divided on the basis of class
size we have five classes depending upon
the requirement of the network plus a
were designed to accommodate networks
with a large number of network hosts
with first bit in the octet is always
zero
with the large number ranging from 0 to
then we have class B
Class B fulfilled the requirements for
medium size Network host where the first
two bits for the network ID is 1 and 0.
with the range from 128 to 191
then we have class C which can fulfill
the requirement for small size Network
host where the first rebirth for network
ID is one one and zero ranging from 192
to 223
from this we get that class A B and C
are used for assigning addresses to the
host Network
and then we have class D which is used
for multicasting which means it is used
to send a signal from one host to
multiple hosts like cubes and video
streaming where the first four bits for
network ID is 1 1 and 0.
with a range from 124 to 239
and lastly we have class E network ID
for this range is reserved for research
purpose and not assigned to any network
with a range from 240 to 255.
Let's see different types of IP
addresses
on the basis of accessibility we have
private IP addresses and public IP
addresses
for private IP addresses the devices are
assigned addresses in a network and each
system is provided with a unique IP
address
which they can communicate through
within the same network
and cannot access public network
and they do provide much more Security
in regards to the public IP addresses
take a look at the public IP address now
for public IP addresses ISP in or
Internet service provider assigns it to
the router which allows a user to access
the internet and also different network
application can be accessed with
security Less in comparison to private
IP addresses
let's now see the other two types of IP
addresses which are static and dynamic
IP addresses
authentic IP addresses is assigned
manually and is constant to the system
whereas dynepic IP address is assigned
by the internet service provider for
static IP addresses the importance is
much more whereas the address is used
for business and is not beneficial to
have different IP each time
in case of dynamic IP address the
assigned IP for network devices do not
need dedicated IP
due to being constant in nature static
IP address is preferred to be assigned
as official address for a business
whereas in case of tiny pick IP address
due to assigning different each time
when it connects to the internet address
provides much better security and often
prevents hacking
now if you want to take a look at the IP
address for a system which is publicly
available we can do by the following
steps
access your internet browser
and type
IP
address
and over here we can take a look at the
public IP address for the system
and if you want to take a look
at the system IP address which is
dedicated to the device you can do the
following steps access command prompt
and write the command ipconfig and you
can take a look at the system IP address
let's take a look at the first heading
that is ip4 addresses
the first version of an IP address to be
developed was based on 32-bit binary
format that counts roughly around 2 to
the power 32 bits of total IP addresses
in ipv4 format
video sufficient at the initial phase of
network requirement but is somewhat
lacking according to the current
advancement in the Network Technology
the addresses in this IP ranges from 0
to 225 in terms of zeros and months with
4 octets where each of them is separated
by a period
this is an example for an ipv4 IP
address
where the first three parts represent
the network ID
and the last part represents the host ID
using the ipv4 address as I reference we
can identify ipv4 addresses from IPv6
addresses
now let's move on to the next topic that
is ipclasses
IP classes are designed to allow easy
and efficient assignment of IP addresses
to a network
depending on class size we have five
different IP classes in a network that
are named as a b c and d
for the first part we have class A
that accommodates network with a large
number of network hosts where the first
bit in the octet is always zero with
number value ranging from 0 to 127
then we have class B
which can fulfill the requirement for a
modded number of network hosts
the lead bit is 1 and 0. and network ID
ranges from 128 to 191.
then we have class C which can allocate
an IP address for Low number of network
host where the first three bits of the
network ID is 1 1 and 0. ranging from
192 to 223
so the above three classes that is Class
A B and C
we can easily identify and assign
addresses to a network host
moving on behalf class D
where it is used for multicasting
that means it is used to send multiple
signals at the same time from a single
host
for example using video streaming
where the lead bit is 1 1 1 and 0. with
network ID ranges from 224 to 239
and then we have class E where the IP
bits for this is reserved for research
purpose only
where the IP addresses ranges from 240
to 255.
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for ipv4 version addresses
where the first is
the memory required for student ipv4
version addresses in a system is very
low
then we have ipp4 version addresses
apply connectionless protocol for
sharing data and providing the best
effort in delivery
moving on we have stacking option for
ipv4 addresses that means in ipv4
version it allows to create a multiple
network over a single host which allows
different hosts to connect to it
moving on we have
ipv4 version addresses being the
earliest IP design are applicable to
most of the network devices and system
for connecting to the internet so it is
supported by many devices
then we have IPv6 addresses let's take a
look
with the increase in the need for an IP
address the ipv4 version addresses are
somewhat unable to complete the
requirements of the network host
so the need for ipv4 version Eros
which is based on 128-bit address size
which is sufficient for a very long time
that is approximately 320 under zillion
IP addresses in version 6.
this type of IPP version is designed of
four hexadecimal digit and 8 sets with
each block containing 16 bits separated
by a colon
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for IPv6 version addresses
where the first is ipv version 6
addresses provides an integrated
security protocol for the network that
is Internet Protocol security
ipsec
then we have it allows its application
to extend in various Services according
to the need of the network
it also allows address configuration
pretty stateful that uses DHCP server
for network settings and stateless that
applies Auto configuration settings
IPv6 addresses also allows some methods
to convert ipv4 addresses to IPv6
addresses
which is according to the requirement of
the host or the network
moving on let's take a look at the
differences between ipv4 version
addresses and IPv6 version addresses
this heading would allow us to choose a
best IP address that we can decide for a
network
let's take a look at the first
difference that is address and
performance
in accordance to the address size ibv4
version is composed of 32-bit address
length and is the fourth version of the
Internet Protocol
for IPv6 we have the address size is 128
bit long and is the latest version of
the Internet Protocol
the second difference is on the basis of
address field type
IPv6 addresses are based on numeric data
with four Fields each separated by a
period
whereas for IPv6 addresses are based on
alphanumeric type data with eight Fields
each separated by a column
the next difference is based on address
configuration
in ipv4 version addresses a manual
setting for the network is required
along with the dhcb configuration
settings
whereas in case of IPv6 version
addresses the network setting is based
in accordance to the systems requirement
and it also supports Auto configuration
setting for the system
foreign
in case of ipv4 the total number of
addresses are nearly 4 billion addresses
whereas in case of ipe6 version we have
320 undecilion addresses
now let's take up a quiz to understand
what we did so far and the question is
identify the correct form of ipv4
version address in the given options
and the options are
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the next difference
that is address security and functioning
ipv4 version addresses do not provide
any security function for the network
whereas in case of IV 6 addresses
integrated Internet Security protocol at
its ipsec it's responsible for the
security of the network
the next difference is encryption and
authentication settings
ipv4 version does not provide any
encryption or authentication services
for the network
IPv6 addresses do provide mandatory
encryption and authentication services
for its addresses
moving on behalf address routing and
performance
ipv4 version follows routing protocol
that has rip for network configuration
and is preferred over IPv6 version
and in case of IPv6 it does not follow
any routing protocols and it uses static
routes for Network functioning
now that we have completed with the
differences between IPv6 and ipv4 we can
easily identify the IP address we want
to choose for our Network
for today's topic firstly we will
understand what is an osr model
then we'll see the structure for the OSI
model continuing with knowing the layer
structure and information in the OSI
model
let's start
to better understand the OSI model let's
take a look at a scenario
assuming we have two different systems
with different operating system
installed in them
and there is a communication Channel
between them over which the data is
shared
but sometimes during transmission of
data it faces some problems
these errors often arise due to the
different operating system installed in
the system or due to a network problem
during a transmission
but to overcome such situations
The OSI model structure is used
using the OSI model structure we can
make the transmission of data over the
communication Channel error free
let's take a look at the definition for
the OSI model
the osm model stands for Open System
interconnection model or a specifically
designed set of protocols and standards
that governs the modeling and conversion
of the data for proper transmission over
the network channels
the osm model is based on the layer
structure where it consists of seven
different layers where each layer has
different set of protocols that are to
be applied on the data during the
transmission over the network channel
let's take a look at the different
layers of the OSI model
the osm model consists of seven
different layers which perform specific
functions and apply different protocols
at different layers to maintain the
quality and prevent the data from
getting corrupted when it is transmitted
over the communication Channel
let's take a look at each of them the
first layer is known as the application
layer which is a topmost layer then we
have the presentation layer
session layer transport layer
Network layer data link layer and
physical layer which is the last layer
of the OSI model
the upper four layers in the OSI model
represents the host layers that is they
interact with the application related
issues when the data is transmitted over
the communication Channel
whereas the lower layers are termed as
networkless
they specifically deal with the
transmission related steps for the data
over the network channel
let's take a look about some information
in regards to the layers
now let's take a look at the function
and the data format that is handled by
each of the layers during the
transmission of data
the first layer is the application layer
which interacts as a Gateway for the
host data and network applications and
handles the data format
then we have the presentation layer
which handles the initial step towards
the conversation of data for transfer it
also handles the data format
then we have the session layer session
layer establishes a connection between
the network devices for the data
transfer
then we have the transport layer which
oversees the data that is transferred
without any error and is in the same
pattern needed by the destination system
the data format handled by this layer is
segment format
next we have the network layer which
determines the part for the data
transfer it handles packet related data
then we have the data link layer which
performs the task of connecting the
physical nodes for the transfer of data
it handles Frame data
and in the end we have the physical
layer which is used to transfer the raw
bits that is in terms of ones and zeros
over the physical mode
now that we are clear about different
layers that are present in the USM model
and some information regarding them
let's take a look at each of the layers
in detail
we'll start with top to bottom that is
the application layer will be the layer
that we'll be starting with
let's take a look
the topmost layer in the osm model is
the application layer which acts as an
interface between the user and the
applications that are being accessed
which can be Internet Explorer Chrome or
any email client
it also handles different protocols that
are needed for the data transmission
over the network channel which can be
given as
hypertext transfer protocol the HTTP
protocol and the SMTP protocol which is
the simple mail transfer protocols
now let's move on to the next layer the
next layer is known as the presentation
layer the presentation layer is
responsible for performing conversion
tasks over the data that is received
from the application layer
the conversion of data is done in
accordance to the required format
it also performs encryption over the
converted data so as to prevent it from
getting hacked by cyber criminals or
hackers
the compression of the encrypted data is
also performed by the presentation lab
so that it can be passed on to the
session layer
the next layer in the OSI model is known
as the session layer in this layer the
communication Channel between two
different devices is established
the network devices are individually
known as session
the data that is transferred is to be
done over these session channels
that layer that is the session layer
establishes and terminates these
sessions in case of an error or some
other unforeseen event
this layer is also responsible for
authentication checks regarding the data
that is mean transferred and also
provides data recovery options in case
an error occurs over the communication
Channel some model list let's take up a
question
the question is what is the mean action
that takes place at the presentation
layer
and the options are
First Option data segmentation second
option encryption of data third option
framing of data and the fourth option
bit conversion of data
you can provide your answers in the
comment section below let's move on to
the next layer
the next layer in the osm model is known
as the transport layer
the main task performed by this layer is
to break the data that is received from
the session layer into different
segments
these segments comprises of protocols
which are UDP protocol and TCP protocol
along with the data that is segmented
from the received data
then the segmented data along with the
UDP and TCP identification it
transferred over to the transmission
Channel where then it's further
transferred to the network devices that
requested for the data
this layer also performs a very crucial
part which is the flow control
let's understand flow control over the
network channel through a small example
in this example the server has a
capacity to send 50 Mbps of data at once
whereas the receiver site has a capacity
for 10 Mbps
when the data is transferred from the
server to the client it transfers 50
Mbps
but it is impossible to transfer all
this data at once due to the lower
capacity on the client side
which is why the flow control changes is
required which is provided to the server
side by the transport layer
now let's move on to the network layer
which is the third layer from the bottom
in the osm model
this layer is responsible for breaking
down the segments into Data packets
by adding IP address to them that it
received from the transport layer
these data packets are then further
transmitted over to the best possible
route to the destination system which
are governed by the internet protocols
including IP and IPv6 protocols
for example if we have a data that is to
be transferred to the network device too
but choose the best option that is the
route to be transferred over to that
Network device
now let's move on to the next layer in
the osm model which is a data link layer
this layer is responsible for
maintaining and terminating the
established connection between the
devices over the network
the MAC address in this layer is added
to the data packets which are
collectively known as data frames these
data frames are then further transmitted
over to the physical Network
these are divided into two different sub
layers
medium access control that is Mac which
controls the established connection
device and the second sub-layer is
logical link control layer LLC which
identifies the address and provide flow
control for the data
this data frame has earlier told is
transferred over to the physical layer
now let's take a look at another
question to brush up whatever we learned
so far
the question is
which layer includes the max sub layer
in the OSI model Option 1 application
layer option 2 session layer option 3
data link layer option 4 transport layer
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the last layer in the
osm model which is a physical layer
this layer is responsible and provides
the physical medium over which the data
frame is transferred
but the transfer data is converted into
bits before it's transferred
the transmission of data is covered by
different protocols that are embedded in
the physical layer
the transmission of ones and zeros
format data is done it also responsible
for maintaining the data quality by
applying different necessary protocols
and maintaining the bit rate throughout
the transfer of data whether it be wide
medium or Wireless medium
now let's get started with the first
topic that is what is an osm model
to better understand the osm model's
role in transmitting data from Network
to another
let's consider we have two networking
devices between which data is being
transferred
the part between the devices is called
Communication channel
let us assume that we
different operating system for the
network channel
to overcome such situation where the
data cannot be transferred due to the
different OS in the system
once a model is used
which uses the seven layer structure to
allow the conversion of data from the
upper model to the data that is to be
transferred
now let's take a look at the technical
definition of the USM model
the osm module stands for Open System
interconnection model
a specifically designed set of protocols
and standards governing the data's
modeling and conversion of proper
transmission
the oyster model is divided into seven
layers which perform specific functions
and apply protocols to maintain data
quality without any error
now let's move on to the main heading
for the session that is what is the
physical layer
the physical layer which provides and is
responsible for physical mode between
the sender and the receiver node in the
data transmission
this layer converts frames received from
the data link layer into bits that is in
terms of ones and zeros to be
transferred
it is also responsible for maintaining
the data quality by applying necessary
protocols and maintaining the bit rate
through the data transfer using wired
and wireless medium
now let's move on to the attributes of
the physical layer
the physical layer has multiple
attributes which is applies in the USM
model
the first is signals the data is to be
converted to signals for efficient data
transmission where it has two different
types
digital signals represents the network
pulses and Digital Data from the upper
layer whereas the analog signal is
converted data for transmission of the
model
the next attribute is known as
transmission medium the network function
is damaged without proper conversion at
the physical layer
it has two different types wide medium
the connections tab list is made through
application of cables example fiber
optic cable and coaxial cable and the
second type is wireless media
connections established using the
wireless communication Network example
Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
the other attributes of the physical
layer are data flow which is defined as
a rate of information flow and the
transmission wireframe
the factors that affect data flow rate
are error rate receiving incorrect data
due to noise in the transmission
encoding encoding data for transmission
over the network channel and the last is
bandwidth that is the transmission rate
of data in the channel
the last attribute of the physical layer
is
noise in transmission
during data transmission the transmitted
data may get damaged or corrupted due to
multiple reasons
some of which are mentioned as
dispersion in this case details is
spread and overlapped during
transmission which causes damage to the
original data
then we have attenuation which is the
gradual weakening of the Network signal
over the transmission Channel
then we have data delay the transmit is
data reaches the destination system
outside the time specified
now let's move on to the role of the
physical layer in a model
the physical layer due to data
transmission ability performs multiple
roles which are the data bit are
converted to physical signals and
transmitted over the channel by the
physical layer
it also integrates multiple electronic
sockets for data transmission and apply
different technological Hardware
it is also responsible for translation
of data that is received from the upper
layer in the ASM model
now let's move on to the last setting
that is importance of physical layer
the physical layer is responsible for
maintaining the communication between
the hardware and the network model
without the physical layer the
conversation of data from upper layer
will halt which leads to collapse of the
communication model
it also handles data flow rate of the
data being transmitted along with the
time frame of the transmitted data
with this we have covered all the
important points and definitions related
to the physical layer in the osm model
let's get started with the first heading
what is the OSI model
The OSI model stands for open system
interconnection Model A specifically
designed set of protocols and standards
governing the data's modeling and
conversion for proper transmission
The OSI model is divided into seven
layers which perform specific functions
and apply protocols to maintain data
quality without any error now let's move
on to the main topic for today's session
which is about what is the physical
layer
the data link layer is responsible for
maintaining and terminating the
established connection between the
devices over the network it has two
sub-layers the first one is the medium
access control which uses the Mac
addresses from the devices to transfer
data between them the second layer is
The Logical link layer which identifies
checks flow control and performs the
error check for the transmitted data
advancing let's take a look at the
functions provided by the data link
layer
but before we begin let's understand the
data flow between the data link layer
and other layers in the OSI model that
is to begin with the network layer we'll
share the data packets with the data
link layer the data link layer handles
these data packets by integrating them
with frame structure where the frame
acts as the header for the data packet
the data packet will contain information
about the destination address sender
address and other related Services the
final product of the data link layer is
known as the data frame which is then
transmitted to the physical layer of the
OSI model now let's take a look at the
list of functions provided by the data
link layer first is framing framing acts
as a header format for the data
then we have addressing which handles
the physical address of the data frame
next is flow control which is
responsible for maintaining proper data
exchange between the sender and the
receiver side continuing with access
control which handles the communication
link between multiple network devices
the last function is error control as
the name suggests ddl provides error
control services to the data
now let's take a closer look at all the
data link layer functions the first one
is framing the data packets received
from the network layer are encapsulated
in frames by the data link layer for bit
to bit sharing over the channel it is
also responsible for restructuring the
framed data in the network model and
each data frame is different from the
others followed by that we have
addressing the task of adding a physical
address to the frame in the header
format is known as addressing it acts as
the identification service for
transmitting the frames to multiple
Network models over the channel
the next one is the flow control during
the data transmission the data flow of
the sender or the receiver side may be
different causing Network congestion in
the channel the data link layer in such
situations acts as a flow control for
the sender side to prevent the Overflow
at the receiver's side
followed by that we have the access
control in this network model when
multiple devices share the same
Communication channel this leads to data
Collision in the model
to prevent such data collisions the data
link layer performs checks on the
devices with the same network channel to
avoid any data loss lastly we have error
control
during data transmission due to noise or
signal loss errors might occur in the
data being transmitted to minimize such
data error rate the data link layer
performs error detection and correction
techniques on the transmitted data error
detection is done by adding detection
bits in the header of the transmitted
data and the receiver site can check for
any error in the received data now let's
take a look at the sub layers of the
data link layer
in the OSI model the data link layer can
be divided into two sub-layers which are
logical link control this is the upper
sub layer of the data link layer
the second one is the media access
control or Mac which is the lower sub
layer of the data link layer but before
we begin with the details regarding the
two sub-layers let's take up a quick
quiz to consolidate what we have learned
so far question
which of the following tasks is not
performed by the data links layer a
addressing b i p Services C framing D
Access Control you can give your answers
in the comment section below
now let's take a look at some points
related to each layer of the sub layers
the first one which is logical link
control this sub layer is responsible
for handling and maintaining the
communication repeat
this sub layer is responsible for
handling and maintaining the
communication between the other layers
of the OSI model
this layer also performs the task of
overseeing the data flow rate of the
channel lastly it is also responsible
for handling error messages and
reliability checks for the data
next we have the media Access Control
this sub layer manages framing of the
data received from the upper layers
this layer also handles the physical
media for the model and interacts with
the computer and IC it is also
responsible for data encapsulation and
media access control for the data
received now the OSI model stands for
open system interconnection Model A
specifically designed set of protocols
and standards governing the data's
modeling and conversion for proper
transmission
the osm model is divided into seven
layers which perform specific functions
and apply protocols to maintain data
quality without any error
now let's move on to the core topic for
this session what is Network layer
the network layer is responsible for
breaking down the segment into Data
packets and resembling them on receiving
end this layer also ensures that the
packets are transmitted over the best
possible route to the destination system
governed by the internet protocols
so now moving forward let us look at the
networks layer function
but before we begin first let's
understand the data flow between the
network layer and the other layers in
the OSI model
that is to begin with the network layer
we will receive data from the transport
layer of the OSI model
the network layer handles these data
packets by integrating them with the
sources and destination address it also
add Network protocol for the proper
transmission over the networks Channel
now let's look at the functions of the
network layer
first we have Internet working
that handles the network channel as the
name suggests
then we have Network addressing followed
by packet routing and packet handling
now let's look at the sum of the points
regarding the functions
first up internetworking it is one of
the main tasks of the network layer to
handle the network connection between
multiple devices in the channel this
task applies multiple protocols
available in the network layer of the
OSI model for stable network connection
next up Network addressing
the network layer does the tasks of
adding the source and the destination
address in the header of the network
channel
the network addressing is performed to
identify the device where the data is
being shared
next up packet routing
now the establishing and routing path
for the data packets is one of the main
functions of the network layer in the
network model
a network layer chooses the most
suitable path out of the line of the
path available in the channel next up
packet handling
in this the network function the layer
handles the data received from the upper
layers of the OSI model the network
layer converts the received data into
the packets for sharing over the
communication Channel
now let's look at the responsibilities
of network layer
the network layer is responsible for
handling the shortest routing path for a
data packet in the network channel it is
also responsible for converting the
received data into packets for
transmission this layer also handles the
network layer protocol which is
responsible for maintaining the
Network's traffic in the channel
The OSI model is a specifically designed
set of protocols that govern
communication channels through which
network devices share input and data
this task of sharing information is
divided among seven layers of DSi model
for micro level network communication
now let's move on to the core topic for
this session that is what is transport
layer
the transport layer is responsible for
overseeing the data being transmitted
and check there's no error in the data
using different network protocols for
example UDP and TCP
then these data segments are shared over
the connection and non-connection
Network Services
it also identifies suitable
Communication channel for the data
now let's move on to the next heading
that is the functions of Transport layer
before we begin with the actual
functions of the transport layer let's
take a look at the data flow that occurs
between the multiple layers of the SR
model and the transport layer
to begin with the session layer
will share data packets over to the
transport layer where it will be checked
for various errors
or corruption in the data received
it is then transmitted into smaller
units over to the next layer
in between this multiple Protocols are
applied in the transport layer for
example TCP UDP a CTP
and then these data segments are shared
over to the bottom layer
now let's take a look at the functions
available for the transport layer
the first is process to process delivery
multiplexing and deep multiplexing
congestion control
flow control and lastly error control
let's move on with each of them in
detail
the first is process to process delivery
function in this function it is one of
the main tasks of the transport layer
that is designed to effectively deliver
data segments to the correct process
among all the working application over
the sender site
this task applies a 16-bit port number
to identify the sender destination
application correctly to transmit data
over the network channel
now let's move on to the next function
that is multiplexing and demultiplexing
the first term is multiplexing it is
also one of the core tasks of Transport
layer to allow simultaneous use of
multiple networks over the sender side
and this is known as multiplexing
whereas demultiplexing is executed at
the receiver end to obtain data from
multiple senders application
now let's move on to the next function
that is
congestion control
this function is used to handle traffic
of data in the network model which
arises you to access data being
transmitted over the network channel
the congestion control of data is
handled in two parts
the first is open loop control which is
applied to stop congestion condition in
the network channel
whereas the second control is known as
close loop control
that is applied to eradicate the
congestion situation in the network
model
now let's move on to the next function
in the transport layer
the next function is known as flow
control
the transport layer performs flow
Management Services in the TCP Network
model in a communication Channel
this channel applies the sliding window
protocol principle
to handle the data flow in the network
model
to know more about the sliding window
protocol principle you can watch our
previous videos
now let's move on to the last function
of the transport layer
the last function of the transport layer
is known as error control
the transport layer also checks errors
in the information received from the
upper layer in the osm model
error detection is performed using the
checksum method or error detecting codes
to check corrupted data
acknowledgment and no acknowledgment
services are used to inform sender if
the receiver has received corrupted or
damaged data through the network channel
with this we have cleared all the
functions related to the transport layer
now let's move on to the last setting
for the session
that is what is TLS
TLS stands for transport layer
Securities the TLs service is
responsible for providing enhanced
security to the transport layer in the
network model
to ensure that the external services do
not affect the data being handled in the
transport layer TLS performs a main role
let's take a look at some of the TLs
services in the transport layer
where the first is known as encryption
which performs encryption procedures for
sensitive data being handled in the
layer
next is hidden many of the TLs services
are invisible to the client side and are
only available to the transport layer
for being used in data
compatibility most TLS services are
available for multiple web browser and
are compatible with multiple devices
with this we have cleared all the points
regarding the transport layer in the SM
model what is an osr model
The OSI or Open System interconnection
model is a specifically designed set of
protocols that govern communication
channels through which network devices
share information and data
this task of sharing data is divided
among seven layers of the SI model
which works at micro level in a
communication Channel
now let's move on to the core topic for
the session that is what is session
layer
the session layer controls and maintains
connection between devices to share data
among them
it is also responsible for establishing
and terminating sessions in the channel
it also checks the authenticity and
provides recovery options for the active
sessions in case of a network error
now let's move on to the next heading
that is functions of the session layer
but before we begin let's take a look at
the actual working steps of the session
layer in a communication Channel
recession layer received data units from
the upper layers in USM model or from
the communication Channel
where it integrates the data with
session address
and the session layer is responsible for
maintaining the dialog between the
system that are connected in the
communication Channel
it applies multiple protocols for secure
and safe transmission for example rtcp
pptp pap
after that the session data is being
transferred to the lower layers in the
USM model
now let's take a look at the functions
of the session layer
whereas the first is session
establishment
then we have data transfer
dialogue managing
and synchronization
let's take a look at each of the
functions in detail
the first function is session
establishment
it is responsible for establishing
connections between systems also known
as sessions
this connection allows user to share
data remote access and find handling in
a communication Channel
it acts as a transport connection that
is accompanied in the session
establishment that is the transfer
connection is mapped when the session is
released
through this connection there are three
ways of Transport connection
which are one to one
many to one and one to many
now let's move on to the next function
that is
data transfer
one of the core functions of the session
layer is to handle exchange of data
between systems in half duplex of full
duplex Network Mode
the session layer also allows the user
to initiate data transfer in case of
half duplex and simultaneous data
Exchange in case of a full duplex
Network model now let's move on to the
next function that is dialog management
the recession layer is responsible for
keeping log data on which the system
established connection to exchange data
this is known as dialog management
it also uses a token method to maintain
the efficiency of The Connection by
giving the token to the user sharing
data in case of a half duplex mode and
then transferring it along with the data
to the next system
now let's move on to the next function
that is
synchronization
the session layer maintains proper
interaction between systems and provides
a recovery option known as the known
state in case of an error
it also uses synchronization points to
be added in the communication channel
for using a known state in case of an
error
with this we have completed all the mean
functions of the session layer now let's
move on to the next heading that is
protocols in the session layer
the session layer provides multiple
Network protocols for security safety
and efficiency between the communication
systems
some of the session layer Protocols are
real name transport control protocol
rtcp
this protocol provides statistical and
controls the information for an RTP
session in the communication Channel
then we have point-to-point tunneling
process pptp this section layer protocol
provides a way to implement virtual
private networks also known as VPN
using TCP in the network channel
then we have password Authentication
Protocol pap
this protocol in the session layer is
used as a password Authentication
Protocol by the PPP control
to validate users in the communication
Channel
with this we have completed all the
important points related to the session
layer in the OSI model what is an OSI
model
The OSI or Open System interconnection
model is a specifically designed set of
protocols that govern communication
channels through which network devices
share information and data this task of
sharing information is divided among the
seven layers of the OSI model which
works at the micro level network
communication in a network model now
let's look into the next setting that is
what is presentation layer
the presentation layer performs the task
of converting data into an uncomplicated
form for the application layer
it is also responsible for encrypting
and decoupling data which is shared over
the network model
it also executes the task of compressing
the data transmission over the network
channel for the lower models now let's
move on to the next setting that is
functions of the presentation layer
before we begin with the functions of
the presentation layer let's take a look
at the general functioning of the
presentation layer
to begin with the application layer will
share the data with the presentation
layer where the presentation layer ndsm
model is responsible for handling the
translation and conversion of data based
on the network protocols and
architecture
some of the protocols applied in the
presentation layer are AFP ICA and lpp
after which this processed data from the
presentation layer is transferred over
to the session layer
now let's take a look at the functions
of the presentation layer
the first function is data
representation
then we have data compression
and the last is network security
let's take a look at the first function
that is data representation
the data storage and the process is
handled by the American code of
information interchange and binary coded
decimal in the presentation layer
it takes data so that the receiver can
understand the data effectively and use
it efficiently
it is also responsible for encrypting
data for data transmission
now let's move on to the next function
that is data compression
the presentation layer also applies
multiple compression techniques to
minimize the data required to present
the information over the network model
the compressed data is much more easier
to transmit and is also transmitted at a
much faster speed
then we have network security
the presentation layer is responsible
for adding encryption at the sender and
the receiver side so that the data is
transmitted with proper encryption over
the network model
it also encrypts data sent over the
network and provides multiple security
protocols for maintaining the encryption
state
for the network model now let's take a
quick recap of all the functions of the
presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible
for exchanging data among computer
devices
and applying multiple encoding
techniques for safety purposes
it is responsible for dealing with
presentation part of the data and
integrating multiple data formats for
efficient data transmission
the presentation layer is also
responsible for formatting translation
and delivery of the data shared from the
upper layers as well as the lower layers
in the OSI model
this layer also manages high level
information increasing data transmission
efficiency over the network channel with
this we have completed all the functions
of the presentation layer now let's move
on to the next setting that is Protocols
of the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible
for maintaining the security of the
transmitted data and ensuring that the
received data is accurate and effective
for the receiver end
this is handled by the multiple
protocols available for the presentation
layer in the network model
some of which are
apple filling protocol AFP
this protocol handles basic Network file
control and is specifically designed for
Mac based platforms
then we have lightweight presentation
protocol lpp
lightweight presentation protocol
provides PCP products with ISO
presentation services in the network
model
then we have network data representation
ndr
this type of presentation protocol is
used to implement the presentation layer
in the osm model and the last protocol
is secure socket layer SSL as the name
suggests this protocol is applied to
provide security to the data being
transmitted over the network channel
by encrypting the data link between the
web page and the data service with this
we have covered all the important points
regarding the presentation layer in an
osr model The OSI or Open System
interconnection model is a specifically
designed set of protocols that govern
communication channels through which
network devices share information and
data this task of sharing and dividing
among the seven layers of the USM model
for micro level is known as the Versa
functioning now let's move on to the
main heading for the session that is
what is an application layer
the application layer acts as an
interface for the user and the
application being accessed
it manages the protocols required by the
application to present the data to the
user
they apply HTTP and SMTP and similar
protocols for the data transmission over
the network channel now let's move
forward with the next setting that is
functions of the application layer
but before we begin let's take a look at
the brief working of the application
layer in an osm model to begin with the
application layer we share data unit
with the lower less
where the work of application layer is
that it acts as an interface between the
user and the system applications it is
responsible for applying multiple
Network functions and protocols to
better understand the data
and edit them for the lower layers
it applies multiple protocols in the
network channel
some of which are telnet DNS DHCP
now let's move on to the functions of
the application layer
where the first function is Network
virtual terminal
then we have file transfer access and
management
addressing
and we learn directory services
let's move forward with the first
Network function
Network virtual terminal
the application allows the user to
connect user system to a Remote device
to access functions and services
to establish remote access for the user
the application layer stimulates a
terminal at the remote host
let's take a look at the second function
file transfer access and management
the application layer through remote
accessing can transfer and manage files
for the user system in a Remote device
the file access of files is handled in
terms of file attributes such as file
structure and the functions applied to
the files along with the features
included in the file system over the
network channel
now let's move forward with the next
function of the application layer
that is addressing
the application layer to establish the
connection between the network devices
requires a need to access addresses
the application layer handles requests
from the client to the server device
this is possible by using the server and
the client address
the server will reply to the client's
address using the DNS service
for addressing reasons
now let's move forward with the next
function of the application lab
mail and directly services
the application layer function is also
responsible for handling email
forwarding and Storage
this function of the application layer
is also responsible for handling access
rights for Global Information on the
network services
with this we have completed all the
important functions applied in the
application layer in an OSI model Lord
let's move forward with the next setting
that is
the protocols of the application layer
the application layer provides multiple
protocols providing software with
multiple protocols for handling data
transmission and accessing the received
data over a remote access channel in the
network model
some of the application layers applied
in a network model are
telnet telnet refers to the
telecommunication Network this
application lab protocol is responsible
for handling access filing over the
internet
telnet protocol uses port number 23. in
the network channel
then we have DNS DNS stands for domain
name system
the DNS service protocol is designed to
translate the domain name into
corresponding IP addresses over the
network channel
the DNS protocol uses port number 53 in
a network model
then we have DHCP
DHCP stands for dynamic host
configuration protocol
which is responsible for assigning IP
addresses to the host Network
the DHCP protocol uses port number 67
and 68 in a network model
the last protocol for the application
layer is
SMTP the SMTP protocol stands for simple
meal transfer protocol as the name
suggests this protocol is designed to
handle meal transmission from one user
to another user
the smtv protocol uses port number 25
and 587 over the network model for
transmission purposes
with this we have covered all the
important points regarding the
application layer in nosm model firstly
we'll understand what exactly is the
model the TCP model is a method of
sharing data and information over the
communication Channel
where the data has to go through each of
the four layer structure of the network
model
where it also performs tasks such as
remodeling of data efficient
transmission and air related issues
each layer has dedicated protocols that
they enact on the transmission data
now let's continue with the protocols
that are used in the TCP model
to understand the protocols that are
used in the TCP model we'll compare it
with the OSI model and if you want to
know more about the OSI model you can
visit a video on the simply learn
Channel
let's begin
the topmost three layers of the OSI
model which are application layer
presentation layer and session layer
collectively refers to the application
layer in the tcbip model where they use
protocols such as FTP file transfer
protocol HTTP hypertext transfer
protocol Tel length and SMTP which is
simple mail transfer protocol
then we have the transport layer from
OSI model which refers to the transport
layer in the TCP model
where they apply protocols such as TCP
transmission control protocol and UDP
user datagram protocol
moving on we have Network layer from the
osm model which refers to the internet
layer in the TCP model
which apply a protocol such as IP
Internet Protocol
icmp internet control message protocol
and arp
address resolution protocol
then we have data link layer and
physical layer from the USM model which
refer to the network access layer in the
TCP module
this layer doesn't exactly apply any
protocol but are connected through
physical medium which includes ethernet
Wi-Fi and cables
now that we are completed with the
protocols regarding tcpip model let's
take a look at the layers in detail
the tcpip network model consists of
different layers where the original
model consists of four different layers
which are application layer transport
layer internet layer and network access
layer then we have the updated model
which consists of layer
application layer transport layer
internet layer data link layer and
physical layer
let's take a look at the layers in
detail
the first layer that we are going to
know about is the application layer
application layer this layer acts as an
interface between the application and
programs that require the tcpip model
for communication
including tasks performed by the layer
such as data representation for the
software application that are executed
by the user and then forwarded to the
transport layer
the protocol supplied by this layers are
HTTP hypertext transfer protocol which
is used to access information available
on the internet then we have SMTP simple
mail transfer protocol which is used to
access email related tasks
moving forward we have the transport
layer this layer is responsible for
establishing connection between the
sender and the receiver device
this layer performed the task of
dividing the data from the application
layer into packets
where they are used to create sequences
which are then transferred over to the
destination device it also performs the
task of maintaining the data that is to
be transmitted without error and
controls the data flow rate
the protocols that are applied in the
transport layer are
TCP transmission control protocol which
is responsible for transmission of
segments over the communication Channel
then we have UDP user datagram protocol
which is responsible for identifying
error in the data that is to be
transmitted over the communication
Channel
moving forward the next layer is the
internet layer
this layer is responsible for the
transmission of data over the network
channel that is they provide a proper
route for the packets to be transferred
over the communication Channel
the protocols that are applied by this
internet layer are IP protocol which is
the Internet Protocol this protocol
assigns a unique address to a physical
system
so that it can be identified on the
internet
then we have arp
address resolution protocol
this protocol is used to find the
physical address of the system using the
Internet Protocol address
in the end we have the network access
layer this layer is a combination of
data link layer and physical layer from
the USM model
where it is responsible for maintaining
the task of sending and receiving data
in Roberts
the raw bits are transferred from the
sender side to the receiver side in the
format of binary digit which are zeros
and ones
let's move on with the advantages of
using the TCP model
the TCP model assigns an IP address to
each of the system that is available on
the network channel so that they can be
identified on the internet
then they are also responsible for
enacting different protocols on the data
that is to be transmitted over the
communication channel the tcpip model
also enables the user and the system to
access different format of data over the
communication Channel
now let's take a look at the last topic
for this session which is the osm model
versus a TCP model
on comparing both of the network models
we get The OSI model consists of seven
different layers whereas the TCP model
comprises of four different layers
The OSI model has separate session layer
presentation layer whereas the TCP model
comprises of a single application layer
the transport layer in the OSI model
provides packet delivery protocols
but in the TCP model transport layer
does not provide any such protocols
the osm model is implemented during
network communication but in case of TCP
model it is used as a reference model
for the network channel
network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network
it architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it
effective network security strategies
employ multiple lines of defense that
are scalable and automated each
defensive layer here enforces a set of
security policies which are determined
by the administrator beforehand
and accessibility of the data and the
network
the every company or organization that
handles a large amount of data has a
degree of solutions against many cyber
threats the most basic example of
network security is password protection
it has the network the user chooses
the recently network security has become
the central topic of cyber security with
many organizations involving
applications from people with skills in
this area it is crucial for both
personal and professional networks most
houses with high speed internet have one
or more wireless routers which can be
vulnerable to attacks if they are not
adequately secured
data loss theft and sabotage risk may be
decreased with the usage of a strong
network security system
the workstations are protected from
hazardous spiral thanks to network
security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network
by dividing information into various
sections encrypting these portions and
transferring them over separate Pathways
network security infrastructure offers
multiple levels of protection to thwart
man in the middle attacks preventing
situations like eavesdropping among
other harmful attacks it has become
increasingly difficult in today's
hyper-connected environment as more
corporate applications migrate to both
public and private talks additionally
modern applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team
Network traffic and infrastructure must
be protected in these cases since
assaults on businesses are increasing
every single day
we now understood the basics of network
security
but we need to understand how network
security works in the next section in
slightly more detail
network security revolves around two
processes authentication and
authorization
the first person which is authentication
is similar to access path which ensure
that only those who have the right to
enter a building
in other words authentication checks and
verifies that it is indeed the user
belonging to the network who is trying
to access or enter it thereby preventing
unauthorized intrusions
next comes authorization
this process decides the level of access
provided to the recently authenticated
user
for example the network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network
based on the network user's role the
process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization
today's Network architecture is complex
and faces a threat environment that is
always changing and attackers that are
always trying to find an extraordinary
vulnerabilities
these vulnerabilities can exist in many
areas including devices data
applications users and locations
for this reason many Network Security
Management tools and applications are in
use today that address individual
threats
when it's just a few minutes of down
times can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place beforehand
now that I know a little about network
security and it's working let's cover to
the different types of network security
the fundamental tenet of network
security is the layering of protection
for massive networks and stored data
that ensure the acceptance of rules and
regulations
and Suppose there are three types the
first of which is physical security
the next being Technical and the third
being administrative
let's look into physical security post
this is the most basic level that
includes protecting data and network to
unauthorized Personnel from acquiring
control over the confidentiality of the
network
this include external peripherals and
routers that might be used for cable
connections the same can be achieved by
using devices like biometric systems
physical security is critical especially
for small businesses that do not have
many resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large firms
when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions
this kind fulfills two functions one is
defense against unauthorized users the
other is a difference against malevolent
actions
the last category is Administrative
this level of network security protects
user Behavior like how the permission
has been granted and how the
authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks
this level also suggests necessary
amendments that have to be done to the
infrastructure
I think there's all the basics that we
need to cover on network security in
which our next topic we are going to go
through two mediums of network security
which are the transport layer and the
application layer
the transport layer is a way to secure
information as it is carried over the
Internet with users browsing websites
emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with the
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connected in
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications
the connection employs lighter symmetric
cryptography to save bandwidth and
processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app layer security can lead
to Performance and stability issues data
theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denial
of service attacks or pdos attacks HTTP
plots SQL injections cross-site
scripting
Etc
most organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web Gateway
Services
Etc
now that we have the theory behind
network security has been covered in
detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security policies
the first two to be covered in this
section is a firewall a firewall is a
type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow ordinary in accordance
to a set of security rules
so more than 25 years firewalls have
served Network Securities first line of
defense they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protector and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some point
the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for sure
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the Internet
the encrypted connection is the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to eavesdrop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of
VPN technology is common in both
corporate and personal networks next we
cover the importance of inclusion
prevention systems in network security
or IPS Frameworks
an intuition prevention system is a
network security tool that continually
scans the network for harmful activity
and responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it
it can be either Hardware or software
it's more sophisticated than an
intrusion detection system or an IDs
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity
the next tool in this section and the
final one are going to be behavioral
Analytics
Behavior analytics focus more on the
statistics that are being carried over
and stored through months and years of
usage
some kind of similar pattern is noted
but the idea administrator can detect
some kind of attack the similar attacks
can be stopped and the security can be
further enhanced
another way I've covered all that we
need to know about network security the
necessary tools and different types Etc
let's go to the benefits of network
security as a poor
the first which is protection against
external threats the objective for cyber
assaults can be as varied as the
Defenders themselves
although they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever can cohort the attacks are
getting
a strong cyber security deposit that
considers routine software updates May
assist Works in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry points
the next benefit is protection against
internal threats
the human aspect continues to be the
cyber security system's weakest link
inside the risk can originate from
current or former workers third party
vendors or even trusted partners and
they can be unintentional careless or
downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
ranges may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive disasters
the third benefit is increase
productivity it is nearly impossible for
employees to function when Network and
personal devices are slowed to a crawl
by viruses and other cyber attacks
during the operation of website and for
the company to run
you may significantly minimize
violations and the amount of downtime
required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls by
the scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email phishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training
another benefit is brand trust and
reputation
customer retention is one of the most
crucial elements in business development
customers today pays a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall
additionally it helps manufacturers get
on the vendor list with bigger companies
as a part of the supply chain which is
only as strong as its weakest link
this opens possibilities for potential
future endeavors and development
it's all really so all for the
theoretical part of network security
after covering so many topics let's go
through a small demonstration to drive
homeless of its importance so what are
the first things we're going to cover is
the installation of nmap
what we're using right now is actually
VMware career running an instance of a
Linux distribution known as parrot
security operating system
security OS is a Debian based Linux
distribution that is Catered more
towards ethical hackers and beneficial
testers the Howard is created mode is it
comes pre-installed with a lot of tools
that ethical hackers need including nmap
so let's say you're using another Debian
based error distribution
if you want to install nmap you can go
with the command of sudo apt which is
the package manager installed and Mac
and just press enter
at this point it's going to ask you for
your administrative password because of
the pseudo command which you have used
now this apt will change depending on
the distribution let's say using a
distribution that is based on our
students that will be different if there
is some other distribution which is
built from scratch the commands will
differ but more or less a lot of the
distributions the mainstream
distributions and people use like Ubuntu
sorry noise Max cement they are Debian
based so you're just going to be using
sudo apt install nmap if you give your
administrator password Here
it's going to see that nmap is set to
manually installed and it is already the
newest version at this point if you do
not have nmap in your distribution it's
going to install the necessary package
files
if I just use the nmap command you can
see some helplines where it basically
says what kind of flags you can use for
some of the most common commands the
version
Etc it gives a small sample for the
usage of nmap
no
the first one of the most basic
functions of nmap is to identify active
hosts on your network
nwap does this by using a ping scan or
sometimes it's called a paint swing this
identifies all of the IP addresses that
are currently online without sending any
packets to these hosts
to run the command we're just going to
go let me just clear the screen for now
another thing you have to do before
running nmap just for our ease of use is
we're going to use the sudo Su command
this will turn our console into an
administrator console so let's say we
want to use some drivers or some action
adapters or anything that requires
administrative permission we don't have
to use the admin password again and
again
foreign
has changed into a hash symbol which
means we now have root access of this
console right now of this terminal
so what we're going to do for the pink C
where we have to check existing course
is we're going to use the command in map
minus s p
and go with the IP address
of the current subnet that you are in
which is always going to be minus 1 2
which always going to be 192.168.1.1
the 24 pack
so this is going to take some time
considering this is going to check all
the hosts in this particular subnet
the command then returns a list of posts
on your network which is this and the
total number of assigned IP addresses if
you can spot like any IP addresses that
you cannot account for in your network
OS server you can then further commands
to investigate them further using nmap
itself
now coming to another feature of NF
which is a very important usage is when
scanning posts and map commands can use
server names IP addresses or even six
addresses a basic and map command will
produce information about the given host
so to run a basic board scan we can just
use the nmap command with that IP
address of the device or the IP address
that we are targeting the port now the
host machine that I am using currently
has this current IP address
if you can see the current IP address is
192.168.1.22 as it's written in the ipv
for address preferred section
so now we're going to try and attack
this host machine using nmap on parent
security operating system
so we're just going to go with the end
map
192 what's it say 122 and press enter
and it's going to start scanning the
host for different services and IAP
address that are being done on this
store
the speed of these scans usually depend
on how quick the processor is and also
how quickly the two machines can connect
with each other but two machines I mean
the virtual machine in this case and the
Machine that is being attacked which is
right now the post machine which is
running VMware Workstation
as you can see the host scanning is
complete for this particular IP address
and you can see the number of ports is
mentioned and the services that these
posts are used for is also mentioned it
says which of these are open for example
53 TCP Port we can see it is closed
while some of the other ports are open
now one more feature of nmap is the
ability to guess the operating system of
the IP address that we are attacking for
that we need to add one more flag
which is going to go with the normal
command is nmap minus o and the regular
address that we are in the processor
attacking
just give a few minutes to run the scan
and it will try and put a small case on
the operating system that this host
might be running
this guest might not always be accurate
but it puts a small idea and this is
much more accurate in the case of
actually Unix based operating system
other than Windows based operating
systems it may be able to detect that if
it is a Windows a Linux MacIntosh and so
on
but it may have difficulty finding exact
single versions which it becomes easier
in the case of Linux because we can
identify different distributions by some
of the kernels which under most of the
vulnerabilities comes from the kernels
and not the particular distributions
as you can see the OS detection guess is
complete and you can see aggressive OS
cases over here which is Microsoft
Windows XP Service Pack or Windows
server and there's the 98 guess that is
mostly uh
like I mentioned if you can guess if it
is a Windows based system you can apply
the vulnerabilities and the exploits
accordingly
now at times you may need to detect
service version and the and similar
information from the open ports actually
this is useful for troubleshooting and
scanning for vulnerabilities or Locating
Services that need to be updated
considering a lot of the new updates are
used to fix these kind of open
vulnerabilities so the flag that we're
going to use in this case is minus SV or
hyphen SV so only this is going to
change with the nmap and the IP address
of the host systems staying consistent a
lot of the services that are being run
on these ports are often not the most
say for example Apache web server which
is a very common web server being used
for even local and Global projects a lot
of the older versions used to have
systems that can allow privileged
escalations or other vulnerabilities
that can allow hacker to get into your
system without even impacting a trace of
it celebrated versions tend to fix these
as quickly as possible and most of these
versions do not circulate in the real
world but can be used for ethical
hacking and testing on how these
benefits and how these vulnerabilities
can be attacked further
now with the SV command scan is complete
you can see that it is mentioning some
of the version of the services that are
being run on the particular post
once again like I mentioned using these
version numbers you can identify
particular vulnerabilities and use the
exploits designed for these
vulnerabilities to gain access to the
system
another thing that nmap does well is
sports scanning which are the basic
utilities actually that nmap offers and
consequently there are few ways that
this command can be customized further
for example to come to start a port scan
we're going to use the flag of my iPhone
P we're going to specify a random port
for example 443 which we know it will be
open because it is the port used by
https connections which is obviously
essential for you to access the internet
and once again we are going to use the
IP address for localhost as the test
machine that are being attacked
as you can see it clearly states that
the 44th report is open as expected now
you can use multiple ports you can check
multiple ports this way for example and
map hyphen people will scan three
different ports 443 80 and 445
I'm going to use the same IP address
again
and it's going to show the state of all
the three ports now you can see this
Filter part here which does not mean it
is open and it cannot be exploited in
any way at least right now maybe if
there is any other survey that is being
run it can be exported further but right
now it is in a filtered condition
that is how we can actually scan for
monitable ports together you can also we
can also use actually in a sport can in
a Range format for example let's say
we're going to scan the ports from 200
to 300. once again going to use the
hyphenkey flag
then the IP address of the system being
attacked
it's going to scan all the posts from
200 to 300 and mention what are the
ports that are open filtered or just
straight up closed
as you can see all the 101 stand ports
are ill ignore state for example if we
try to scan a range in the more
reasonable range for example uh four
four three two
four percents that's it
will give the IP address similar
and you can see two of them are open and
two of them are filtered for different
reasons this is how you can find out
which of the posts are reliable for
exploitation before attacking these kind
of devices
imagine our houses without a fence or
boundary wall this would make our
properly easy accessible to trespassers
and robbers and place our homes at Great
risk right
hence fencing our property helps
Safeguard it and keeps trespassers at
Bay
similarly imagine our computers and
networks without protection this would
increase the probability of hackers
infiltrating our Networks to overcome
this challenge just like how boundary
walls protect our houses a virtual wall
helps Safeguard and secure our devices
from Intruders and such a wall is known
as a firewall the firewalls are security
devices that filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic within a private
Network
for example
if you were to visit your friend who
lives in a gated community you would
First Take permission from the security
guard the security guard would check
with your friend if you should be
allowed to entry or not if all is well
your access is granted on the other hand
the security guard would not Grant
permission to a trespasser looking to
enter the same premises here the entry
access depends solely on your friend the
resident's discretion the role of the
security guard in this case is similar
to that of a firewall the firewall works
like a gatekeeper at your computer's
entry point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network
when you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network
this is when a firewall comes to your
Rescue by acting as a barrier between
your computer and the internet the
firewall rejects the malicious data
packet and thus protects your network
from hackers on the other hand
from trusted websites is allowed access
to your network
this way a firewall carries out quick
assessments to detect malware and other
suspicious activities thereby protecting
your network from being susceptible to a
Cyber attack
firewalls can either be Hardware or
software software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network Linksys routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall
besides this there are other types of
firewalls designed based on their
traffic filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall
if the incoming Network traffic is not
for the predefined rules that traffic is
blocked a variant of the packet
filtering firewall is the stateful
inspection firewall these types of
firewalls not only examine each Network
packet but also checks whether or not
that Network packet is part of an
established network connection such
firewalls are also referred to as
Dynamic packet filtering firewalls our
next type of firewall is called a proxy
firewall this draws close comparison to
how you give proxy attendance for a
friend like how you take the authority
to represent your friend the proxy
firewall pretends to be you and
interacts with the internet they come
between you and the internet and thereby
prevents direct connections
this protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks
only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they are
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content cyber crimes are
today making headlines every day and
individuals and companies must do
everything possible to secure their
information hence using security devices
that helps Safeguard our networks from
falling prey to deadly cyber attacks is
the need of the hour what is ipsec
ipsec Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network channel
this protocol was initially defined of
two main protocols for data security
over a network channel which work
authentication header
which is responsible for data integrity
and anti-replay services
and the second protocol is encapsulating
security payload in short ESP which
includes data encryption and data
Authentication
now let's move on to the next setting
that is why do we use ipsec in a network
ipsec is used to secure sensitive data
and information such as company data
clinical data Bank data and various
sensitive information regarding an
institution
which I use during data transmission
over a network channel
the use of vpns that are virtual private
networks and apply ipsec protocols to
encrypt the data for end-to-end
transmission
let's continue with why do we use ipsec
services
also used to encrypt data for
application layer in the osm model and
provide security for sharing data over
Network routers and data Authentication
let's take a look at the working of ip6
services
to begin with we have two different
systems system one and system 2. which
will establish a network channel
and then the encryption of data will
takes place when one host will share the
data to the second host
during this
ipsec services will secure the data that
is to be transferred over the network
channel
by applying router encryption and
Authentication
now let's move on to the next topic that
is components of ipsec
the ip6 services comprises of multiple
protocols that ensure the data
transmission
over the network channel the first one
is encapsulating security payload
protocol in short ESP
this protocol of Ip security provides
data encryption and authentication
services
and it also authenticates and encrypt
the data packet in the transmission
Channel
moving on we have authentication header
in short ah
similar to ESP the authentication header
also provides all the security services
but it does not encrypt the data it also
protects the IP packet and adds
additional headers to the packet header
the modified IP datagram looks this way
where the IP components are included at
the second position
the seventh position and the sixth
position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network channel
moving on we have
internet key exchange Ike
this protocol provides protection for
Content data and also changes the
attribute of the original data to be
shared
by implementing sha and md5 algorithms
they also check the message for
authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver site
for example this is the original data
packet we are used to with IP header
part TCP UDP and data
whereas this is the modified ipsec data
packet where ESP header is added between
IP header and the TCP protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is modes of ipsec
there are basically two types of ipsec
modes available for data transmission
over the network channel
where the first one is tunnel mode this
mode of transmission is used to secure
gateway to Gateway data
it is applied when the final destination
of the data is to be connected to a
sender site through a connection Gateway
over the internet
for example we have two hosts host a and
host B through the host a we are sending
a message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at host a point
and it passes through a gateway to goes
B then
this is a basic format for Gateway to
Gateway data transmission
and the given IP datagram format is used
for tunnel mode
now let's move on to the second mode of
ipsec that is transport mode
this mode of ipsec is used to protect
protocols like TCP or UDP and is used to
ensure end-to-end communication unlike
tunnel mode
the transport mode data at
authentication header and encapsulating
security payload for security purpose in
the IP header
this is the modified IP datagram for
transport mode
the point to be noted is the ipsec
header is always added between IP header
and TCP header
now let's move on to the last setting
for the session on ipsec that is the
working steps involved in IP security
in general there are five steps involved
in the working of ipsec to ensure data
transmission over a network channel
the first step is host recognition in
the first step the host system will
check if the packet is to be transmitted
or Not by automatically triggering the
security policy for the data
which is implemented by the sender side
for proper encryption
then the second step is known as Ike
phase one in this step the two host
devices the sender and the receiver site
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network channel
it is comprised of two modes
the main mode this provides much better
security with a proper time limit
and the second mode known as aggressive
mode as the name suggests it establishes
the ipsec protocol much faster in
comparison to main mode
let's move on to the third step which is
Ike phase 2.
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to
apply over the session in the network
channel and the secret key for the
algorithm to be used to encrypt the data
for transmission
then we have ipsec transmission this
step involves the actual transfer of
data over the network channel
using various protocols used in ip6
security
which are implemented under the tunnel
condition
and the last step is ipsec termination
after the completion of data exchange of
session timeout the ipsec terminal is
terminated and the security key
established is discarded by both the
host system
what is Network address translation
the motive behind implementing Nat is to
allow several network devices to connect
to the Internet by single public address
the NAT model is a method to conserve IP
addresses by using a unique address to
represent the whole private Network
and the mentioned public IP address is a
globally recognized IP address to access
the internet
let's move on to some more details
regarding Network address translation
the task of nat process is to translate
a private IP address in a network to a
globally recognized public IP address
and vice versa
that is the same process begins from
public IP address to a private IP
address
this task is performed by a router or a
Nat firewall
let's move on
the flow of this process is something
similar like the router configured acts
as an interface between the private and
network and the public network
that means the private network will
communicate with the router when it
wants to access an internet
same is the case for public addresses
too when the public address wants to
communicate with the private Network the
router will convert it to a private
network ID
and allow us to access the internet
the reason behind applying math process
is to conserve public IP addresses
to be more specific it's ipv4 addresses
and it also provides much better
security to the network
now let's move on to the next topic
Nat addresses
there are different types of terms used
in that process
more specifically there are some
addresses information that are necessary
to understand the process which takes
place during Network translation
we will discuss them one by one
let's take a look at the first address
before we begin let's take a look at the
example
this is a general or any simple form of
nat translation process
we have a private Network
a private device a router a public
network
that we can access Internet through
the first term that is used is known as
inside local address
this IP address represents the host of
the private Network
and this cannot access the internet
directly unless provided by an ISP
server
after we have the inside local address
through the private Network we share it
with the router
when the router receives this private
network ID it converts it to the public
network that is known as
inside global address
this IP address represents the whole
private Network
for the outside Network
and is used to access the internet for
the private Network
now let's move on to the remaining IP
addresses for Nat
according to this example now we are
returning from a public network to the
private Network please keep that in mind
according to this
the address type next comes up as
outside global address this IP address
represents the outside Network address
for the host before that process took
place
then we have outside local address this
IP address represents the actual address
representing the host on the internet
after the net process takes place
now let's move on to the next setting
and the topic choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
types of math
there are different types of nut
available on the Internet or in the
network channel but we will discuss
three generally used ones
where the first one is known as static
Nat
according to static Nat process
in the given private Network each device
will have a particular or a single IP
address publicly
designed to them
that means if you have two devices in
your private Network you'll have two
different types of public IP addresses
for each of those IP addresses
that is available in your private
Network
due to this property of the static Nat
process it is also known as one to one
Nat and it's mostly used for personal
addresses
for example please take a look at the
diagram below
if we have a single IP address
in a private Network
we will have a single public IP address
for the same
again if we have another private IP
address in the private Network we will
have a public IP address for the same
this represents static Network
let's move on to the next one
the next type of map process is known as
Dynamic Nat
for the dynamic Nat process
private Network addresses is translated
to public addresses from a pool of
public IP addresses available to the
communication Channel
that is
something similar to this
according to the example if we have two
private addresses available in the
network then we have two pool of public
addresses too out of which we can
convert the private address to a public
address
and for example if we have a third
private address and only two possible
public addresses pool then the third
address is dropped
let's take a look at the diagram for a
clarification
this is the pool of public addresses
available for this network
out of which we converted
192.168.32.10 to
213.18.123 to point hundred
now let's move on to the last type of
nut available
this Nat is known as port address
translation
in Port address translation of Nat the
process takes place something similar
like this
all the available private IP addresses
in the private Network are converted to
a single available IP address publicly
recognized
that means if you have five private
networks in your available Network you
will have a single public IP address
available to all of them
due to this nature of this process it is
also known as not overload
but the catch is all the addresses in
the private network available will have
different port number assigned to
differentiate between them
for example
192.168.32.10 is translated to
213.18.123.100.11
where 101 represents the
port number
similarly for the second private Network
we have
192.168.32.12 which translates to two
one three point one eight point one two
three point hundred that is similar with
the earlier case
but the change comes over
0.102 that is the port number assigned
to the second private address
now let's take up a small quiz to
refresh all the topics that we read so
far
and the first question is
what does outside local address refer to
in that your options are name of insight
Source address before translation
name of destination host before
translation
name of inside host after translation
name of outside destination host after
translation
please read the options very carefully
to answer this
now let's move on to the next question
and the question is
Pat address is also termed as
part refers to port address translation
option a static net
option b121 Nat option C Nat overload
and option D not overlapping
you can give your answers in the comment
section
now let's move on to the last heading
for this session that is
advantages and disadvantages of applying
Nat in a network channel
let's take a look at the first advantage
of using net
mat provides privacy and security
measures to the private address as it
converts a private address to a public
address
through which we can prevent a ID from
being hacked over the internet
let's move on to the next advantage
that process is applied to conserve
approved IP addresses over the network
channel as discussed earlier in the
previous slides
net process helps to conserve us ipv4
addresses
now let's look into some disadvantages
of applying Nat in the network channel
and the first disadvantage is net
translation leads to part delay and
prevent some applications
to lose their access over the network
channel
now let's take a look at the second
disadvantage
according to the NAT process router is a
one that translates a private address to
a public address or vice versa
during this process it does happen to
tamper with the port numbers as we
already discussed but according to the
rules set by the network channel
router is not usually allowed to hamper
with the port numbers but it has to
because of nat let's begin with the
introduction to the network hub
a network Hub is a device that is
designed to connect multiple Network
units in a closely connected Network
channel
so hubs are also were used in Lan
Networks
the network Hub shares data with the
destination device by acting as a
central connection point of data
transmission and connecting all the
other devices in the channel
some points to remember about the
working of a hub Hub is incapable of
processing any complex protocols due to
the absence of intelligent unit in the
system
also the physical model of the Hub is
composed of multiple sockets for
connecting network devices
now let's move on to the working of a
network hub
for the first scenario we will assume
that a message is being sent through the
Hub to a destination node
let's begin
according to the example Hub has
received a message for device a
where it will share the same message to
device a
which is a basic protocol
but due to the absence of any
intelligent unit or a processing point
in the hub device it will share a
message for a to all the other connected
devices that are device p as well as
device C
this creates a lot of access of traffic
in the network channel
now let's move on to the second scenario
which is when receiving a response from
the device
in this case when the device a shares a
response to the hub to be sent to the
sender device it will share the same
response to all the other connected
devices again due to the same reason
that is lack of any Processing Unit or
intelligent point
in the network channel
please take a look at the arrow points
which is very important during the
transmission of data
with this we have clear all the points
that are important for a network Hub now
let's move on to the next topic that is
information on switches
the network switch is a networking
device that is active in the data link
layer of the OSI model and is designed
specifically to connect private networks
in a lan Channel
switches are programmed to share
messages only with the designated device
that is mentioned in the header format
of the message
which cuts down the network traffic in
the channel
switches uses different types of data
which can be either packets or data
frames
switch uses destination Source address
and the destination address for
forwarding the message to the specific
device in the system
now let's look into the working of a
network switch
the first scenario is when the message
is received to a switch and is to be
forwarded to a particular device
in this case we are receiving a message
for device a
which will be shared only to device a
according to the address mentioned in
the header format
this
decreases the network traffic in the
channel and also prevent
the access of message to device B and
device C
this task of managing the address and
sending the data to the designated
device is handled using Mac address
which is used by the network card
installed in the network device
now let's move on to the second scenario
that is receiving a response from the
device in this case the switch will
receive a response from device a
which will be forwarded to the sender's
address mentioned in the message
and this will prevent the response to be
shared to device B and device C due to
the presence of a processing unit in the
switch
with this we have completed all the
important points
to be known regarding a network switch
now let's move on to the third topic
that is information on routers
let's begin
a network router is a device that is
designed to share data between multiple
networks at a much larger scale in
comparison to a hub or a network switch
it is connected to multiple devices at a
very large level
that can be considered as metropolitan
area network or a wide area network
router uses IP addresses to share data
with a specified device in the network
channel
and they also perform the task of
translating an address that is available
in a private Network to a globally
recognized Network
so that it can access Internet
which is known as Nat
Network address translation
if you want to look further in the
translation process that the router
performs you can visit our video on the
same in the simply learn Channel
now with this we have completed all the
introduction points regarding a network
router now let's move on to the working
of a network router
in this scenario a message has been
received by the router for device a
from which it will deduce the IP address
for the device a and share the data
the message deliver efficiency is
highest in case of a network router as
it uses routing path from a routing
table to guide the message to its
destination point
and vice versa
with this we have completed all the
important points regarding a network
router now let's move on to the last
setting for this session that is
difference between a network Hub switch
under router
for this difference we will use
different features to differentiate the
working of a hub switch and a router
the first difference is based upon the
OSI model layer
in case of a hub it is active in the
physical layer of the OSI model that is
also known as the first layer
and in case of a switch it is active in
the data link layer of the OSI model
also known as the second layer
whereas a network router is active in
the network layer of the SI model also
known as the third layer
now let's move on to the next difference
that is based on addresses used by each
of them let's take a look
a hub as we already discussed doesn't
use a MAC address or an IP address for
the transmission of data in the network
channel
in case of a switch it uses Mac
addresses available in the network
channel to provide a guidance system for
the message to be transferred
whereas in case of a router it uses IP
addresses to transmit the data to the
designated device
let's move on to some other differences
that is format of data used in each of
them
Hub uses electrical signals or bits for
data transmission in a network channel
whereas such uses a data frame or data
package for the transmission of data
over the communication Channel
and in case of a router it uses data
packets to be transferred
and the next difference is based on the
mode of transmission
let's take a look for this
a hub is based on half duplex network
connection that means at a certain point
of time only a single device can share
or receive data from the other endpoint
of the network channel
and in case of a switch it is full
duplex network connection that means it
can simultaneously receive and send a
data packet or a data frame to any of
the network devices connected in the
system
similarly a router is also based upon
the full duplex network connection form
let's move on to the next difference
that is installation purpose
on the basis of installation purpose a
hub is mainly preferred in a lan Network
or in a private Network where two to
three devices are to be connected which
increases the efficiency due to the
absence of a processing unit in a hub
as for a switch it connects multiple Lan
networks or a large area network
available
as for the case in a network router it
is a Global Network that connects
multiple devices across the globe and is
also designed to connect internet to any
of the device
let's take a look at the next difference
that is device classification
in case of a hub it uses broadcast
format or a broadcasting device to
transmit data over the communication
Channel due to the absence of any
Processing Unit in the system
and in case of a switch it uses
multicasting application for the
transmission of data
and in case of a router it uses routing
path from a routing table to transmit
the data in the communication Channel
let's take a look at a few more
differences
that is installation cost
a network Hub can be installed very
easily in a network channel as it does
not perform any complex task
in case of a switch
it required moderate cost installation
as it performs some complex queries or
complex protocols in the network channel
whereas in case of a router it is the
most expensive to install in the network
channel due to the high device picks and
the Performance Based protocol
and the next difference is based upon
processing and intelligence
now that we are clear a hub device does
not have any Processing Unit or
intelligence point
and is the most basic point of data
transmission
whereas in case of a switch it possesses
a processing unit
to differentiate the destination address
or a source address in the header format
of the message
whereas in case of a network router it
is a more sophisticated device among all
the three network devices as it performs
the most complex queries and protocols
in the network channel what are
switching techniques
switching techniques are network
techniques responsible for overseeing
the transmission of data over different
communication channels they are also
responsible for choosing the best route
for data transfer
next we will look into why to apply
these switching techniques
using the switching techniques we can
choose the best and the most efficient
route for data transfer in the network
for example if we want to send some data
from node a to node B we can do so by
moving from node a to a switch then node
D then to node B but doesn't this seems
like too long this is where the
switching techniques plays its role
using the switching Technique we can
choose the smallest and the most
efficient way that is no day switch then
to the node B
next we will look into different types
of switching techniques
switching techniques can be divided into
three primary types the first is circuit
switching
that requires a predestined path for
data transmission
then we have message switching which
integrates the destination address with
the data for transmission
and in the end we have packet switching
that divides its message into smaller
units known as packets
packet switching can further be divided
into two different types that are
virtual switching and datagram switching
now let's look into some details
regarding each of the types
on the first note we have circuit
switching
in circuit switching for data
transmission to occur a pre-established
path is required between the sender and
the receiver node
for example
assume that we call someone then this
request is sent over to the network
searches
and a root is to be established for the
signal to pass through
after that system assigns a route for
the signal to pass through then
the receiver receives the call from the
caller side
this is how it works
now let's look into some points to
remember about socket switching
for circuit switching we require a
dedicated Channel established between
the source and the destination node for
the network to pass through
the data transmission can take place
only after the path established
and the last point to remember is other
than the sender and the destination node
no node can interfere with the
transmission of data to the established
route
let's look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying circuit
switching in a network
for first one we have advantages
data transmission in circuit switching
its sure to be established due to the
predestined path
circuit switching is preferred for long
uncontinuous transmission of data due to
the pre-established path route
then let's look into some disadvantages
the time required to establish the
connection is quite long due to the time
required to establish a path
also due to the continuous transmission
of data in circuit switching more
bandwidth is required for maintaining
the connection
let's move on with message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established between the sender and
the destination node in the message
this technique integrates the
destination address into the data
transmittal and shared over the network
let's look into the setup to better
understand the working of message
switching
for First Step the sender node
integrates the destination address into
the message
then the whole message is transmitted to
the switching node in the network where
it gets stored for the next transmission
and similarly like the Second Step this
transmission of data is done over the
whole network
and finally
through the destination address in the
data it reaches the receiver's node
this is how the message switching works
let's take a look at some points to
remember about message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established
it uses Dynamic routing as the message
is transmitted through the communication
channel in real time
the each node in network switching
stores the data unless it is transferred
over to the next switch load
let's take a look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying method
switching
to begin with let's take a look at the
advantages
the size of the data that can be
transmitted over method switching is
variable
in message switching the use of
bandwidth is done in an efficient manner
now let's look into some disadvantages
for message switching the nodes that are
known as the switch node is to be
provided with sufficient storage memory
there is a delay in reaching a
destination due to the message technique
that is the message has to stop at each
of the switch node before it is
transferred over to the destination node
now let's look into the last switching
technique that is packet switching
in packet switching the message is
broken into smaller data units known as
packets
these packets are appended with relevant
Network details for the transmission
over the network
let's look into the working of packet
switching
we know that in packet switching the
data is broken into smaller units
packets
which each packet is given a sequence
number for identification
these packets are integrated with
required sender and receiver address and
switching method to choose the smallest
route to reach the destination node
these packets are then recombined at the
destination node in the correct sequence
order
now let's look into some points to
remember for packet switching
for packet switching all the data
packets that are provided with unique
number for identification at the
receiver end that is
1 2 3 and 4 in the previous example we
just used
packet switching chooses the most
shortest part possible for the data to
reach the destination
in case we have unreached packet or some
unattained packet the whole message from
the sender site is sent again
to the receiver end
now let's look into some details
regarding advantages and disadvantages
of applying packet switching
advantages of using packet switching is
it provides rerouting in case the
network node is busy
it also allows multiple users to access
the same network and no predestined path
is needed
the disadvantage of applying packet
switching is the protocols that are
needed for the working of packet
switching is very complex
there are often cases of lots of data
packets during the transmission in case
of overloading or Corruption of data
the C idea or classless interdomain
routing is a network concept designed to
oversee the assignment of IP addresses
to a system to replace the outdated way
of classful addressing system
furthermore using the cidm method there
is low wastage of IP addresses and it
also is helpful in maintaining the
routing table
and it performs the task of subnetting
which saves a lot of IP addresses now
let's move on to the next setting that
is rules of using cidr
to better understand the working of CID
addressing in the later part
please take a look at the rules very
seriously
let's take a look at the first rule that
is the IP addresses assigned are
according to the C idea
are to be continuous
as the ISP will provide them in a
sequence to minimize the address wastage
for example if we have an IP address
200.10.18.32
then the addressing will take place as
200.10.18.33
and moving on to the end position
as mentioned in the example this proves
that they are continuous in assigning of
IP addresses let's move on to the next
rule that is the number of addresses in
a cidr block is to be power of two that
is in case the number of addresses is
odd then its invalid value
for example
2 to the power 4 is equal to 16.
therefore represents the number of hosts
whereas if the value is 17 then it's an
invalid value as for the last rule we
have
use of cidr block for notation purpose
that is for example if we have 200 or
11.19.34 slash 28 as an IP address then
the block ID of this IP address is 28.
and the host ID is 4 which is calculated
using 32 minus 28 because in an ip4
address 32-bit is the maximum limit
now let's move on to the next setting
that is working of cidr
the CID are addressing applies the
variable length subnetting masking that
is vslm for short as the basis of its
working method
that is used to break the conventional
IP addresses into smaller sub networks
of varying sizes according to user
requirement let's take a look at an
example to understand the working
process
in the given example the IP address is
195.10.20.40 16. now let's solve the
question to begin with from the giving
my P address we can determine the
network prefix that would be
195.10.20.40.
whereas the suffix represent the slash
16 part
the number 16 in an IP address represent
the number of ones in the address that
is known as the block ID or the network
ID
and the host ID is determined using 32
minus 16 because 32 is the maximum limit
of bit length in an ipv4 address
so the host ID is 16.
and the total number of hosts that are
available in the network is calculated
using 2 to the power number of hosts
that would be 2 to the power 16 for this
case so the value is 65 536 available
host in this given network ID now let's
move on to the examples to better
understand the working
the first example is
the given IP address
192.168.200.10
28 and we have to find the relevant
information
let's begin for the first step convert
the IP address in a binary decimal
format that is
for this IP address it would be
the given binary format
now let's find out the network mask for
this IP address that would be
28 once and four zeros the point to be
noted is according to the slash number
we point the number of ones for Network
mask
for example in this question we have
slash 28 so the network mask has 28 ones
beginning from left to right and the
last four digit would be zero
and in numerical form the value comes
out to be
255.255.255.240.
and this is the network mask for our IP
address
now let's move on to the next
information that is network ID
the network ID for the given IP address
is calculated using
this way
by the given subnet mask that is slash
28 we assume that
192.168.200 does not change because it
is a part of network ID
and the point to be noted is the network
ID is never to be tampered with
only the host ID can be used to change
the value that means we will open the
dot 10 path in binary format that would
come out to be zero zero zero one zero
one zero
then
change once to zeros
and perform
the and operation after performing the
and operation for the last four digit
that is the host ID part we will get
192.168.200.0 slash 28 that represents
the network ID for the given IP address
similarly we can find the number of
First that would be easy that is 32
minus 28 that is 4 and the total number
of hosts would be 2 to the power 4 that
is 16.
and the first host ID in this given IP
address would be 192.168.200.1
with the completion of this example we
have completed all the relevant Parts
regarding cidr working introduction to
the algorithm
the distance algorithm was invented by
edscar w dextra
this algorithm were designed to find the
shortest path
between the nodes of a communication
Channel
the distance algorithm is also used to
form a shortest part table for the given
graph
and it works on the principle of greedy
algorithm
now let's move on to some key points
regarding the algorithm
the first key point to be noted to solve
a distance algorithm is the algorithm is
closely linked to position of the nodes
in a graph
the next point is the attribute value
between the nodes of a channel
is used to deduce the shortest path
as for the last point we have the
initial value of all the nodes from the
current node is assumed to be infinite
to much practically understand the
functioning of the dextra's algorithm
let's take a look at the principle for
the same
the principle of the algorithm works as
if the distance of U that represents the
current node plus the length that is the
attribute value between node U that is a
current node and node V that is the
target node is less than the attribute
value to distance of the target node
and also the distance of the target node
is equal to the distance of current node
plus the length between Target node and
the current node
where distance U represents the source
node or the current node
and distance V represents the target
node or the destination node
to much better understand let's apply
this
for the given question let's find the
shortest path
in this given example we have three
different nodes node a b and c
using the previously discussed algorithm
principle we will deduce the shortest
path
for node 8 to the other nodes in the
graph that is the shortest path from
node a to node B and the shortest path
from node a to node C
for this let's take the node B first
according to the solution it should be
for node B on applying the algorithm
along with the values we have if 0 that
is the position of a is zero plus the
target node attribute value that is 10.
is less than equal to infinite that is
initially as mentioned infinite value is
to be assumed
and this statement stands true so the
distance between node a to node B
becomes 10.
for the third step we will look into
distance between node a to node C that
would be 0 plus 40. that is the direct
connection between node a to node C
according to the example Which is less
than infinity again true so the distance
between note a to node C is 40.
Moving on but we have to find the
shortest path
so for this fourth step comes into
picture
that is for node C from node B on
applying the algorithm we have 10 that
is the initial value of node B and plus
15 that is the attribute value between B
and node C
which is 25 and is less than infinity
so the shortest path between node a to
node C becomes 25 instead of 40 which
was given through step 3.
using the same scenario and same steps
we will solve a much difficult question
and understand how the algorithm is used
then without further Ado let's move on
to the solved example using the textras
algorithm
according to the given question
we have to use the distress algorithm
for the given graph and find the
shortest path from node a to node C
the point to be noted is we need to find
distance that is shortest between node a
to node C mining
now let's take a look at the graph
and this is the given graph
with node a at the current node and node
C is to be the targeted node
but before we begin with the solution
for the given graph let's take a look at
some of the important points to remember
the first point the distance of node a
from all the other nodes is infinite in
the starting step as discussed earlier
in the example graph
the next point is the node with the
shortest value will become the next
current node
then we have
this graph is done to maintain a proper
shortest path value table which will be
very helpful during the solution of the
graph
now let's move on to the solution
to begin with we will make
shortest path table value
that is given through this
with three columns in it node column
value column and previous node
now let's start with the actual solution
to begin with the first step is to Mark
the current node that is node a
then the nodes that are directly
connected to the current node that is
node B and node d
Now using the value distance that is 3
for node a to node B and 8 for node a to
node D we will update our
table
where the point to be noted is that we
have updated the previous node as a for
both the nodes B and D
moving on now let's choose the next
current node that is
node B
for the next case because the shortest
path in the given table is 3 which is
less than 8.
now
the directly connected nodes to node br
no D and no d
similar to the case we did earlier we
will Mark the shortest distance from
node B to node D and OD let's reduce the
distance
the distance between node B to node D is
3 plus 5 that is equal to 8.
and then we have
distance from node B to node D that is 3
plus 6.
so the value is 9.
now we will update our
shortest path table and the new table
comes up to be
from node d
to node B we have 8 and node B to node e
we have 9. with the previous node as B
moving on let's decide the next current
node that is
D because the shortest distance is 8 in
comparison to 9 for node e
so the new current node is node D and
the directly connected nodes to node D
is node e and node f
the point to be noted is the current
node is chosen only from the unvisited
nodes
now for this we have
distance between node D to node e is 8
that is the previous value we deduced
plus 3 that is the distance between node
D to node d and the total value comes up
to be 11.
then we have to node F from node T that
is 8 plus 2 that is the distance between
node D and node f
so the value becomes 10.
on updating the shortest path graph
table we have
the new distances that is node F has 10
value with the previous node as D and
there is no change with the node d
because in comparison to 8 11 is much
bigger
moving on let's choose the next current
node that is node e because in
comparison to value 10 from node F 9 is
smaller
now the node e is a current node and the
directly connected nodes are node F and
node C
now let's find the value between node C
and node e
that will be 9 plus 9 that is the
distance between node e and node C so
the value totals from up to be 18.
and for node F and node e we have 9 plus
1 that is the distance between node e
and node F that comes up to be 10.
now let's compare with the graph table
where node f is originally at Value 10
and again the value is 10 so there's no
change and see we have infinite and the
value 18 is much smaller so the new
graph would be something like this with
node c as 18 value and previous node as
e
now let's decide the next current node
that is
node F because the distance value is
lowest in the given graph that is 10 and
for node C is 18.
and the directly connected node is node
C
then the distance comes up to be 10 plus
3 that is 13.
using this 13th value we can decide the
current value of C is 18 and the new
value is 13. in comparison 13 is
obviously less so the new graphs comes
out to be
for node C value 13 and the previous
node becomes f
with the completion of all the nodes in
the given graph we can deduce the
shortest path from node a to node C that
comes up to be
from node a to node D node D to node F
and node F to node C
and the total value comes up to be 13.
with this we have covered all the parts
regarding the functioning and the
working steps involved in the dikshas
algorithm
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section introduction to distance Vector
routing
distance Vector routing refers to the
distance or the vector that is between
the neighboring nodes
in a network channel
and the routing part refers to the
established route through which data
packets are transmitted in the network
channel
the other aspect of this routing
protocol in a network channel is to
determine the shortest path for a data
packet in the network to reach its
destination
next we will look into some key points
regarding the routing protocol
for routing protocol three primary key
points are to be remembered
first one being
each router in this protocol is designed
to share the vector data of each node
throughout the network
this step is done to maintain proper
circulation of data in the network
channel
the next key point is the routing
pattern in the network protocol
that is the data shared by the routers
is transmitted only to those nodes that
are directly linked to a particular
router
the last key point is that the routing
protocol is designed in a manner that it
shares the updated Vector data
periodically at the network channel
now let's move on to the next heading
that is the algorithm used in the
protocol
the algorithm used in this protocol is
termed as Bellman fold algorithm
this algorithm defines the shortest part
that the data packet can take to reach
its destination node from my initial
node
where
V of X Y refers to the least distance
from a node X to node y
moving on we have C of X comma V where X
is caused from each of its neighboring V
node is taken into consideration
then we have D of v y
this is a distance of each neighbor from
its initial node
and lastly
Min or Phi this is an abbreviation used
to determine the most shortest Vector
after the solution is obtained using the
algorithm
in the next heading that is Network
example we will understand all the
points used in the algorithm
now let's design a network model with
five different nodes
that are a b c and d with each node
connected to each other using different
network channel
the numerical values in the network
channel refers to the vector count that
is the distance from node a to node b or
to some other node in the network
channel
in a network model each node share its
Vector data with its neighboring node at
a regular interval as there are various
updates in the network model
this data is shared in a form of routing
table where three different columns are
used
first being destination column second
Vector column that is the distance node
and lastly the Hop
let's take a look at the neighboring
nodes for this model
for node a we have b and e as it is
directly interlinked to the node a
for node B we have node a and node C
for node C we have B and D
for D we have c and e and lastly for E
we have node a and node d
these nodes represents only the
neighboring nodes
now let's solve an actual example on
routing protocol to clear all our doubts
and understand the key points
the example we'll be taking to solve is
this network model
the initial step to start solving the
network model using the distance Vector
routing protocol is to make routing
table for each of the nodes
let's make the routing table for node a
this is the routing table for node a
where we have destination as a
that means destination is a from node a
that means the distance Vector should be
zero
then we have destination as B
let's take a look in this given example
there is no given connection between A
and B that means
this distance Vector would be Infinity
then we have destination as C
similarly as node B there is no direct
connection between a and node C that
means this is also Infinity
and same is the case with node d
and in the end we have
node e that is the only directly linked
node
to note a that means the distance given
is 5 so the network Vector is 5.
let's make an another routing table for
node e
this is the routing table for nodi
let's take a look
in this routing table the first is
destination to node a
according to the network model given
distance is 5 so the vector value is 5
but the Hop to pay
then we have
destination as node B according to the
model the distance Vector should be 4.
then we have destination as node C as
given this no direct connection between
node e and node C that determines the
value would be Infinity
then we have node d
which represents
direct connection with node e and the
value is 7. and lastly
e destination from initial Point e would
be zero vector
now let's make another routing table
similarly for node C
Now using the same steps you can make
the routing table for the remaining
nodes that is node B and node d
now let's move on to the next step in
solving the routing issue
this step is known as update step in
this step we use the vector column from
each of the node to update the vector
column or the routing table for a
particular node
in this part we'll use
node is Vector column to update the
routing table for node a
and the steps are using the algorithm
that is the Bellman fold algorithm we
used earlier
as we already know moving from a to
destination node a is always zero so we
won't be doing this step let's move on
to the next one that is moving from node
a to node B
that would be
would be a comma e as we are using
Vector column of node e
plus and the distance used to reach E
from B
a comma e represents 5.
and E to B represents 4 according to the
network model so the value is 9.
similarly let's solve for a to c
to a to c we have a comma e plus
destination required to move from E to C
according to the network model we have
node a is only directly linked with node
e so the value would be 5 but there is
no connection between node e and node C
so the value would be Infinity
moving on we have
a to d
in this case we have a comma e the value
would be 5 plus e to D that is a direct
connection and the value would be 7 so
the total distance is 12.
and the last one is a to e for this we
have a comma e that is directly the
neighboring node the value would be 5.
so the new routing table for node a is
0 9 Infinity 12 and 5.
similarly let's take another node for
this
for the next node we will take node C
and we will update the routing table of
node C using its neighboring nodes that
are
node B and node D according to the
network model
now how to do this step
firstly it's C to destination a
in case of node B we have
C to a that would be C comma B that is a
direct connection plus distance required
from B to a
according to network model we have C
comma b as 6 plus b to a does not have
any connection that is infinity so the
value would be null
then we have node D in this case we have
C comma D that is a direct connection 3
plus d to a that is again Infinity
as it is not linked directly to node a
moving on we have destination as B
for node B we have direct connection so
C comma B value is 6. whereas for node D
we have
C comma D that is distance 3 plus d to B
that is infinity as it is not directly
linked with the node B
so again the value is null
then we have
destination as C so connection between C
to C is 0.
moving on we have destination at node d
that would be C to d as C to D
as there is no direct connection between
node B and node D so the value is
infinity
whereas for C to D is a direct
connection for node D so the value would
be 3.
now for the last node that is node e
in case of node B we have C comma B plus
b to e where the value for C to B node
is 6 and B2 is 4 so the sum is 10.
and now in case of node D we have
3 plus 7 that would be distance from C
to D and then D to e and the value would
be again 10 so we can use any of the
side to reach the destination node e
by completing all the steps we have the
new table for node C
similarly we can find the routing table
for all the nodes present
now to look into some key points we
learned
for the initial step use only the node
distance of immediate Neighbors
nodes without distance that is directly
linked to each other is always infinity
for the update step use the vector table
of the only neighboring node we have for
the initial node
and lastly to continue the update step
roughly n minus 1 iterations are used
where the value of n is equal to the
number of nodes
for example the model we took has five
nodes that means we have to do a loop of
four iterations what is hdlc
let's take a look
the hdlc stands for high level data link
control refers to the bit oriented
Network protocol design to connect
multiple Network system according to the
communication requirement
the hdlc model applies the arq protocol
for application and establishes a full
duplex Communication channel between the
network devices
moving on we have the different types of
hdlc stations available
hdlc stations can efficiently be
differentiated into three different
types where the first type is primary
station
in this station it handles the
establishing and destablishing of the
primary data channel to share different
frames in the network channel
known as commands
it also performs the data management for
the network
moving on we have the secondary station
this station work under the command of
the primary station and the frames
issued by the stations are known as
responses
as for the last station we have combined
station as the name suggests this type
of station is available for both
commands and response value
next we will look into hdlc transfer
models
the hdlc protocol supports two types of
transfer models which are applied
according to the need of Communication
channel where the first type is known as
normal response model or in short nrm
this transfer model combines the primary
session and the secondary station in a
point to point or multi-point
configuration
to exchange commands from primary
station and responses from the secondary
station
and response to the multi connection
moving on we have the second type of
transfer model which is asynchronous
balanced model
in this transfer model the combined
stations are installed in a
point-to-point configuration for
exchange of command or responses from
either of the node
moving on let's take a look at the hdlc
frame model and types
the data unit for sharing information in
the hdlc protocol is known as frames
the hdlc frame consists of multiple
frame fields which may varying according
to the frame type
in general the hdlc frame consists of
five different frame Fields where the
first field is flag field
in hdlc each frame starts and with the
flag field in the configuration and is
defined by an 8-bit octet sequence which
is 0 1 1 1 1 1 0 in the flag field
moving on we have the address field it
encapsulates the receiver's address in
the field for example if the frame is
sent from the primary station it
contains the secondary station's address
and vice versa
next we have the control field this
field contains the flow and error
control information in byte format
next we have payload or the information
field it carries the actual information
from the upper layer of the OSI model
and the last field is known as FCS field
this field stands for frame sequence
check
and acts as an error detection field in
the hdlc protocol which includes a 6-bit
CRC check
given is a frame format for an hdlc
protocol with flag in the both ending
and the starting point followed by
address field control field information
field and FCS field
now let's take up a quiz
to understand all the things we have
learned so far
the question is
the hdlc protocol functions under which
network layer in the USM model
and the options are
application layer data link layer
physical layer and the network layer
you can give your answers in the comment
section now let's move on to different
types of frame models available in sdlc
the free models in hdlc can be
classified of following three types
depending upon the control field value
of the frame
where the first frame is known as iframe
the iframe stands for information frame
and is applied to encapsulate the user
information from the upper layer in the
model
and then transmit it to the network
channel
note the first bit of the control field
in this Frame is always zero which also
acts as an identification point for
iframe
moving on we have the S frame the S
frame stands for supervisory frame and
is used for error and data flow control
and does not contain any information
regarding the information field in the
format
not for the S frame s the first two bits
of the control field is 1 and 0. which
acts as an identification point for S
frame
as for the last type of free model we
have U frame the u-frame stands for
unnumbered frame used for system
management and exchanging information
between connected network devices
with this we have covered all the
relevant information regarding the hdlc
protocol
the checksum is one of the most applied
error detection method in the network
channel
and is a bit based format detection
method
the checksum uses checksum generator on
the sender side perform the checksum
method and the checksum checker on the
receiver side to check whether this an
error in the data or not
let's continue with the next setting
that is why to apply checksum method
using the checksum method at the center
side the checksum value is added to the
original data to being transferred as an
error detection method whereas at the
receiver side it decodes the incoming
data from the sender side according to
the checksum method
to detect any changes in the given data
now let's move on to the working steps
involved in the checksum method
there are various steps involved in the
checksum method let's take a look at the
first step that is the first step begins
at the sender site where we divide the
original data into K Paths of n Bits
continuing with adding all the cave
blocks we have obtained
then the addition result is complemented
using one's complement
the data now obtained is known as the
checksum value
next let's look at the step 2.
data transmission after we have received
the checksum value from the checksum
method we will add it to the front of
the original data and transfer it to the
network channel to the receiver site
now step 3
step 3 begins at the receiver site that
is
it will divide that is the receiver side
will divide the obtained original data
plus each XM value into clay box
and then add all the K blocks using
addition
after that we will complement the
obtained data if the complement of 1
comes out to be 0.
that is no errors are received in the
data
and the receiver will accept the data
whereas for case 2 if the result is not
0 the received data is damaged
so the receiver will discard this data
and request for retransmission of data
from the sender side
now after understanding all the points
regarding working
of the checksum method let's take a look
at a solved example to better understand
all the points
the question is for the given data
perform the checksum method
this is how we divided all the four
parts
each of these represents a k block that
is four blocks and eight bits in each of
the block that is n Bits
now for the first step that is at the
sender side
we will add all the given data
so the value would come out to be one
zero zero zero that would be 1.
0 1 0 0 would be one
zero zero one one would be one carry 0
so 1 carry plus one means zero plus one
carry again
one carry plus one means zero and one
one zero one that is one carry 0 plus 1
plus 0 means one so one carry is over
this side
one plus zero is one one plus one is one
carry zero zero plus zero zero zero plus
zero is zero and zero and we have one
carry over here
so the obtained data would be one zero
with extra bit as this
now to resolve this issue we will now
add the extra carry to the obtained data
from the addition part that would be
one zero one zero zero one zero zero
now
add the sender side you will do one's
complement for the obtained addition
value that would come out to be one one
zero one one zero one zero that is the
checksum value
now this value addition to the original
data will be shared to the receiver side
where at the receiver side we will again
perform the addition method
and the value comes out to be
this along with two digits of extra bit
that is the carry again similarly we
will add this carry to the addition
value and get the new data that is all
ones
now again going by the steps we have to
perform one's complement for this value
obtained that comes out to be all zeros
that means the checksum value is 0 at
the receiver side which indicates that
there are no errors in the received data
by the receiver side
with this we have completed all the
points regarding working of the checksum
method now to better understand all the
steps let's take up a quiz
that is for the given data find the
checksum value where
the given options can be one of them you
can give your answers in the comment
section what is peritable check
the parity bit is a data checkpit added
to the original data for detecting
errors at the receiver Side by checking
the Integrity of the received data
the parity bit adds 1 or 0 to the
original data that is to be transmitted
to the receiver side
and if in case there is an error in the
received data the center side will do
the penalty check and give the request
for retransmission of the data
now let's move on to the key points
regarding pair debit check
to properly understand the working of
parity bit check
we need to understand some key points
where the first one is redundant bits
where the extra binary width that are
added explicitly to the original data to
prevent the damage to the transmitted
data or to detect the damage to the
transmitted data
they are also used to recover the
original data in case of a damage at the
receiver end
the number of redundant bits added
depends upon the type of check method
used
regarding which in this example there
are four data bits used whereas three
redundant bits
it can also be two redundant widths
or one redundant bit
in case of parity check method only one
redundant bit is added to the original
data
now let's move on to the next key point
that is
parity bits
the parity weight check method is a
method to add binary bits to secure the
original data
that is done by counting the total
number of ones in the original data
which is either even or odd number
the parity bit check method is used to
detect error in the original data at the
receiver side and also in some cases it
is used to correct the change
there are two types of priority bits
available to choose from the first one
is odd predictable in this parity bit
check the number of ones in the original
data including the parity bit should be
order number for example
in the given example the number of green
tiles has four ones that is even so the
parity bit should be one in this case to
make the total number of ones in the
data 5 that is odd
similarly the other parity bit is known
as even parity bit in this case of
parity type the total number of ones
counted is to be even including the
parity bit for example
the number of ones in green tiles is
four that is even so the value of parity
bit should be 0 in this case
the point to be noted is the parity bit
value should always be correct because
it acts as the error detection method at
the receiver site
now let's move on to the explained
example to consolidate all the things we
have learned so far
the question is for the given data bit
that is one one zero one one apply the
even parity bit check for data
transmission
now let's begin
for the first step let's take the
original data that is one one zero one
one one
and the parity bit value is to be given
as p
now according to the next step we have
to count the number of ones in the
original data
which will come out to be
5 bits that means there are five ones in
the original data which represents an
odd number
to balance this according to even parity
bit now we have to add 1 in place of P
so the new data to be transmitted will
become 1 1 0
1 1 1 and 1.
which will be transmitted to the
receiver site
by the sender side
after the data has reached the receiver
side there are a few cases that may
arise in the data
where case one is the data we received
to transmission has no errors that is
the data received is correct after
applying the parity with check
which in this case is even
so the transmitted data is this
and the received data is this that means
both the transmitted data and received
data are same that means the received
data is correct then the second case
arises is the data bit received two
transmission has errors that is the data
received is damaged after applying the
even parity check
which in this case the transmitted data
is
and the received data has an 0 instead
of one
which means the number of ones in this
case becomes 5. which does not match
with the even parity check so it has an
error
and the last Case Case three in this the
data bit received through transmission
has errors that is the data received is
correct according to the event parity
bit
because the transmitted data has six
ones whereas the received data has four
ones but according to even parity check
only the number of ones should be even
that means the number of ones received
by the receiver side is 4 so according
to parity bed check it is valid but
according to the original data the
received data is wrong
these are the three main cases that may
arise during the transmission of data
through parity check method the Heming
code method is a network technique that
is designed to detect errors and
corrects data bits which are transmitted
during data Exchange
it was first implemented by RW Hamming
hence the name Amin code
this network technique is implemented
because during data transmission there
are often cases where data loss or data
damage occurs to recover or detect the
damage in the original data we use ham
encode
in the next slide we will look into some
terms that are related to the working of
Hamming code
the first one being redundant width
these are the extra binary bits that are
added explicitly to the original data
bit
to prevent damage to the transmitted
data and also to recover the original
data in case of a damage at the receiver
end
in the next point we will look into some
formula related to redundant bits and
how to add them in the Hamming code
the formula related to redundant bits is
to are more than equal to M plus r Plus
1. where M refers to the data bits in
the data and R refers to the Redundant
bits
let's take an example
in case m is equal to 4 that means the
data bits used are 4 we need to find the
value of r
using the above formula let's deduce the
value of redundant bits
2R is more than equal to 4 plus r Plus
1.
2 to the power r is more than equal to
R plus 5
so using this let's use r equal to 0 if
we use that we will get a value 1 that
is more than equal to R plus 5 but that
is wrong
then using r equal to 3 that is 8 is
more than equal to eight
this way we conclude that the Hamming
code would be 7 bit data because the
value of R is 3 and M is 4.
now let's move on to the next
term related to harming code
that is parity pills the parity bit is
the method to append binary bits to
secure that the total number of counts
of one in the original data is either
even number or an odd number
let's take a look why do we exactly use
parity bits they are used to detect
error in the original data which occurs
during the transmission of data
through this method
we can detect the error at the receiver
end and also correct it
let's take a look at different types of
parity bits available
first one is even parity bit in this
case of parity type the total number of
ones counted is to be even in the count
in case the count is odd then the value
of parity is 1.
otherwise the value should be zero
similarly the other parity bit is known
as odd parity bit
for this parity bit the total number of
ones counted in the original data should
be odd
if that is the case the value of parity
bit should be zero and in case the value
of ones in the original data comes out
to be odd then the parity value would be
1.
now let's move on to the next setting
that is a working example of the Hamming
code
let's take a look
let's begin with the steps to be
followed to solve a Hamming code issue
the first point being the position of
the parity width is determined using 2
to the power n term where n represents
the number series 0 to n
assigning the position for parity bit
using this method would be more clear
giving an example
for the second point we have the
remaining positions represent the data
bit
now let's try using the value of parity
bit for n is equal to 0 that means 2 to
the power 0 is equal to 1. so all the
bits with one in the last position are
used to determine the value
of the parity bit
to better understand the assignment
value of parity bit please focus on this
mention table
in this table we can take a look at the
last position that is n is equal to 0.
and see the mentioned number
for P1 we can use a value 1 because n is
equal to 0 and the last position value
is 1.
then is number three because the last
position beta is one
then similarly for number five because n
is equal to 0 and the bit value is 1.
so these three parity value can be used
for and is equal to zero
similarly let's take a look when the N
is equal to 1.
that means 2 to the power 1 is equal to
2. so all the bits with one in the
second position are used to determine
the value of parity bit
now let's take a look at the table to
identify the numbers related to this
parity bit value
the first one being to due to the
presence of one bit in the second
position
then we have P3
presence of one bit in the second
position
similarly the next would be number six
due to the presence of one bit in the
second position
similarly let's take a look at when n is
equal to 2 that means 2 to the power 2
is equal to 4 so all the bits with 1 in
the third position are used to determine
the value of parity bit
and this would be 4 5 and 6 number
please read the points very carefully
because next we will solved an example
to better clarify all the concepts
let's move on
we give an example is the data bit to be
transmitted is one zero one one
and we have to solve this using the
Hamming code method
so the first step would be applying the
Hamming code method and identify the
given number of data bits that would be
four according to the question
so the number of parity bit would be 3
where the value would be 1 2 and 4.
according to the power of P expression
that means
we will get something similar to this
this representation is in data bit
format
where the first position is for P1
parity bit
the second for 2 to the power 1 that is
2. P2
and the third one is for 2 to the power
4 that is P4 parity
and let's put the value that is to be
transmitted in the remaining positions
that would be P1 P2 1 p 4 1 0 and 1.
using this bit value we will deduce the
value of P1 P2 and P4 for data
transmission
in this case we are using even parity
for the example
that means the number of ones should be
even
let's take a look
for P1 we have D1 D3 D5 and D7
as mentioned in the earlier slide
so the value would be P1 comma 1
comma 1 and comma 1 according to the
data bits available to us by the
question
that means the value would be 1 because
the number of ones for P1 is odd
so to make it even the value of P1 would
be 1.
similarly for P2 we have D2 D3 T6 and D7
using the same method we will get
P2 1 0 1. so the number of ones for P2
is even so the P2 value would be 0.
next is for P4 the value is D4 D5 D6 and
D7
where P4 has 1 0 and 1 that means the
number of ones is even so again P4 is
equal to 0.
Now using this we get the new bit that
is to be transmitted
that is one zero one zero one zero one
after Transmission in case let's say at
position 5 another Argus
and the value of 1 is converted to 0.
to detect this error at the receiver
side we will use the Hamming code
to begin with we will use the parity
value to cross check the original data
bit that means let's do the parity bit
method for this received data
so for P1 we have D1 D3 D5 and D7
so the number of ones is odd that means
the value of P1 should be 1 to make it
even
then for P2 we have
D2 D3
D6 and D7
so the number of ones is even
that means the P2 value would be zero
now let's move on for P4
that would be 4
D5 D6 and D7 so number of ones is one
that means odd so the value of P4 would
be 1.
now let's take a look at the results
that we obtained using this method
foremost this shows that the data
transmitted is damaged and we can detect
the error position using this method
that is using the value of parity bits
obtained
where this will lead to 2 to the power
expression that means 2 to the power 0
plus 0 plus 2 to the power 2 that means
5.
that matches with the Assumption we took
now to correct this error we can use
the position that we obtain that is 5.
and replace the zeroth value with one
bit
by doing this we will obtain the
original data
now let's move on to the first heading
that is Introduction to the protocol
the stop in read protocol is a type of
flow control mechanism active in the OSI
model of the data link layer the
transmission of data applies only to the
noiseless channels
where a noiseless channel represents an
ideal Network channel where no frames
are lost duplicated or hacked
moving on we have the Stop and rate
protocol is unidirection in transmission
of data that is either sending or
receiving data will only takes place at
an instance
for the third point we have
the Stop and rate protocol as the name
suggests is when the sender shares a
data packet to the receiver end
then the sender side has to stop and
wait for the receiver side to send an
acknowledgment before it starts sending
the next data packet
with this point we are now knowledgeable
about the working of the Stop and read
protocol at an elementary level
now let's move on to the next heading
the next setting for the session is
steps involved in the Stop and weight
protocol
the steps for this protocol are divided
into two parts sender and receiver
protocol
let's start with the sender site
the first step is to transmit one data
unit at a time to the receiver End by
the sender site
and the next step is
to transmit the next data until Only
After we receive the acknowledgment from
the receiver end
now let's move on to the receiver side
in receiver side step one is to receive
the data and use the data that is being
sent
then the second step is after the data
has been used by the receiver side it
will send the acknowledgment to the
sender site for further data
transmission
this is how the transmission of data
takes place in the data protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is working of stop and weight
protocol
using the previous two headings we can
easily determine the steps involved in
this working
let's take a look
to begin with we have two sides the
sender and the receiver side
the first step is
to send the data from the sender side to
the receiver end
and after the receiver side has used the
data it will send the acknowledgment
signal
meanwhile the sender site has to wait
for the acknowledgment signal
only after it receives the
acknowledgment signal will it send the
next data packet
now that the sender site has sent the
data for the second time the receiver
site will use this data and then only
share the acknowledgment signal
this process of sending data from the
sender side to the receiver side and
receiving acknowledgment from the
receiver side to the sender site
continues for n number of times
according to the given scenario in the
network channel
now let's move on to the next heading
that is also the last setting for this
session that is drawbacks of using stop
and read protocol
the first drawback of using this
protocol is the loss of data
this issue can arise when transmitting
data from the sender site to the
receiver end
it may be due to any issue
due to hacking attempt or network
disruption or any other network related
issue
then
this can also arise when receiving
acknowledgment from the receiver site
now let's move on to the second drawback
the next issue is related to
acknowledgment transmission that is
during the transmission of
acknowledgment signal due to the network
issues
technology signal is disrupted
and the transmission is terminated
this can arise again due to any reasons
that are occurring in the network
channel
now let's move on to the last drawback
for this heading
the last issue occurs due to the delay
in transmission time of the information
time delay drawback can occur on either
side of the transmission that is during
data transmission or the acknowledgment
transmission as we know in a networking
concept protocols refers to the rules
and instructions
that governs the data transmission
between different network models and
devices in a communication Channel
the data transmitted using protocols is
easily handled and is reliable to use as
well as it provides a secure channel for
the data to be transmitted
now let's move on to the different types
of protocols available in a network
channel
the protocols available in a network
channel can be divided into two
different types noiseless channels and
noisy channels
where the noise part refers to any
external interference data error or
duplicate Transmission in the network
channel
furthermore noiseless channels and noisy
channels can be divided into
subdivisions let's take a look at the
noiseless channels first
noiseless channels can be divided into
two types simplest type and stop in
weight type
whereas noisy channels are divided into
three subdivisions stop and wait arq go
back and arq selective repeat arq
in the noisy Channel go back in arq and
selective repeat arq are the ones that
apply the sliding window protocol for
data transmission over the network
channel
now let's look into some information
regarding sliding window protocol
to begin with the sliding window
protocol is a technique that allows the
share of multiple data frames in a
network channel
where the number of frames shared is
determined by the window size assigned
to the network channel
also the frames sent during transmission
are assigned with a sequence number for
efficient train Transmission in the
communication Channel
till this point in the video we have
already learned about the definition of
what is the sliding window protocol
now let's look into the working steps of
the sliding window protocol
to begin with we have a center site and
a receiver site in the network channel
then we require the frames where each
frame is given a sequence number for
this example we are using 0 to 8. which
means a total of 9 frames are available
at the sender side
then using the window size we determine
the number of frames that can be shared
at an instance for example we'll be
using three as a window size for this
example
let's start with sending the first frame
that is zero
to the receiver side
after the frame is sent a sliding window
appears on the number of frames
now let's move on to the next
that is frame one
the point to be noted is
before receiving any acknowledgment we
have to send all the frames that are
available according to the window size
that is for this example the window size
is 3 that means we have to send three
frames before we receive any
acknowledgment from the receiver side
let's send the last frame that is frame
2.
now we have to wait for the receiver
site to send the acknowledgment signal
to the sender site before we can send
the next frame now that we have shared
the maximum number of frames the
receiver end will share the
acknowledgment signal for frame 0 with
the sender side after this
acknowledgment is received by the sender
side we can share the next frame in the
list that is frame 3.
after the frame 3 has been sent
see the positioning of the sliding
window
the sliding window now changes from 0 1
2 to 1 to 1 3 frame
this positioning of the sliding window
represents that zeroth frame has already
been acknowledged by the receiver side
whereas the third frame is sent for
acknowledgment from the receiver site by
the sender site
and similarly we have to do the same
pattern for the next two frames that is
frame number one and frame number two
now the sender side will receive the
acknowledgment for frame 1 from the
receiver side
and we can send frame 4 from the sender
side to the receiver site
now see the movement of the sliding
window
the sliding window changes from 1 to 1 3
frame number to 2 3 and 4.
similarly we can move on to the last
frame
now let's draw some simple conclusion
from all the working steps we have seen
so far
to begin with frame number one and zero
represents the acknowledged frames
whereas the frames within the sliding
window represents
the frames that are waiting
acknowledgment
whereas the remaining frames 5 6 7 and 8
are not yet shared with the receiver
side
now let's move on to the next heading
for the session
difference between stop and weight
protocol and sliding window protocol
the first comparison is on the basis of
working mechanism
where the Stop and beat protocol is
designed to send the data frame at a
single time and wait for the receiver to
send the acknowledgment to share the
next frame
as for the sliding window protocol
sender can send multiple frames
simultaneously and then wait for the
corresponding acknowledgment from the
receiver end
let's move on to the next comparison
that is based on the window size
on the basis of window size the Stop and
rate protocol is always fixed at 1.
as for sliding window protocol as we saw
in earlier slides it varies according to
the scenario in the network channel
let's take a look at some other
comparisons too
the next comparison is based on
efficiency and time delay as comparison
on this basis the Stop and read protocol
is efficiently low and suffers from more
time delay
as for sliding window protocol the
efficiency is higher than the Stop and
weight protocol which provides lower
time delay during data transmission
let's move on to the last comparison
sorting and transmission of data
for stop and read protocol sorting is
not required
and it applies half duplex system for
data transmission
as for sliding window protocol we
require sorting for better efficiency
and is full duplex in nature
with this we have reached the end of the
video now let's look into some
information about the go back and arq
protocol
this protocol applies the sliding window
method for transmission of data in the
network channel
where n in the protocol refers to the
window size assigned in the network
model
as for the term arq in the protocol
refers to the automatic repeat request
which means the sender side will send
multiple data frames to the receiver
side according to the assigned window
size
and only after it receives an
acknowledgment from the receiver site
will it continue to send the frames from
the sender side
moving on let's look into some important
points regarding the protocol
as to begin with the method applied to
share multiple frames from the sender
side to the receiver side is known as
the protocol pipelining
where each frame is assigned a sequence
number for proper transmission of data
in the network channel
now let's move on to some other
important points
as we already know
the n in the protocol refers to the
window size that is the maximum limit of
frames that can be transmitted from the
sender to the receiver side before
reaching the acknowledgment for the
previous frame
and in case if the transmission of the
acknowledgment of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be re-transmitted in the
channel
this point is to be remembered properly
because this will be the key point in
solving a question related to go back in
arq protocol
now let's move on to the working of the
protocol
to begin with we have a sender site and
a receiver site along with the sequence
number
the window size for the network channel
and the number of frames will already be
assigned in the network
Now by applying the sliding window
protocol we will send the first three
frames from the sequence continuously
which will be frame number zero
frame number one and two
this is assigned according to the window
size
after sending the frames we will have a
sliding window over the sequence number
that are 0 1 and 2.
after the frames are sent to the
receiver site it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgment signal to the
sender side
that would be 0 for the first time
after which we can share the next frame
that will be frame number three from the
sender side to the receiver side
after sending frame 3 the sliding window
from sequence number 0 1 to 2 will shift
over to 1 2 and 3.
and similarly
for frame number one we will receive the
acknowledgment signal from the receiver
side to the sender side
and then we can share the next frame
that is frame number four from the
sender side to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift over
from sequence number 1 2 and 3 to over 2
3 and 4.
as for the next frame that is frame
number two when we receive the
acknowledgment from the receiver side
there is a catch
for any network issues the
acknowledgment is not received by the
sender site
so in this case as discussed earlier in
one of the important points the sender
side will not transmit frame number
five instead it will re-transmit frame
number 2 3 and 4.
where the second frame is the one which
did not receive the acknowledgment and
all the frames sent after second frame
is to be retransmitted along with it
that is 3 and 4.
to much better understand the solution
for the example we'll be solving later
in the video it is suggested that you
watch the steps involved in the working
of the go back and arq protocol again
now moving forward let's take a look at
some of the advantages and disadvantages
of using the protocol in a network
channel
for advantages we have it increases the
efficiency of transmission of frames
it also allows multiple frames to be
sent at once
and the time delay is low for sharing
the packets
as for disadvantages we have
the tree transmission of frames in case
of an error in the network channel is a
very difficult work
and it also requires the storing of
frames on the receiver side that it
receives from the center side
now that we have learned everything
about the go back and RQ protocol let's
take a look at the much awaited working
example for the same
let's take a look at the problem
statement
in a given Network the number of frames
provided is 10
with the window size assigned as 3 and
for every fourth packet is lost
find the total number of messages or
frames sent from the sender side to the
receiver site
from this question we can get three main
parts that are the number of frames that
are given is 10.
as for the window size is 3 and every
fourth packet is lost
let's take a look at the options
option a27 option d25 option C 22 and
option d29
I'll give you guys a moment to take a
look at the question again
now let's move on to the solution
as usual we have the sender side and a
receiver side
and according to the question we have 10
frames
dumping the frames sequentially we have
frame 1 to frame 10.
and then according to the question we
have window size as three
Now using the sliding window method
we'll send the first three frames that
is frame number one two and three from
the sender side to the receiver side
that will be
like this
after sending the frames we'll wait for
the receiver side to send the
acknowledgment
and a sliding window will appear on
frame number one two and three
now the receiver side will send the
acknowledgment for frame 1 to the sender
side
foreign
number 4 from the sender side to the
receiver side
and a sliding window appear on two three
and four sequence number
and similarly for frame number two we'll
send the acknowledgment from receiver
side to the sender site
and send frame number 5 from sender to
the receiver side
and the sliding window appears on
sequence number 3 4 and 5.
then again for frame number three we'll
send the acknowledgment from the
receiver side to the sender site
and send frame number 6 from the sender
to the receiver side
and the sliding window appear on frame
number 4 5 and 6. now let's move on for
the next frame for acknowledgment that
is frame number four
for this Frame according to the given
question every fourth frame is lost
during transmission from the center side
to the receiver side
that means no acknowledgment will be
sent from the receiver side to the
sender site for frame number four in
that regards or any other frame that are
sent after frame number four that is
frame number five and frame number six
similarly frame number five and frame
number six will also get discarded
now let's re-transmit according to the
go back in arq protocol
frame number four
frame number five and frame number six
after re-transmission frame number four
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side to the sender side that means we
can send next frame that is frame number
seven from the sequence order
and the sliding window appears on frame
number five six and seven
similarly let's move on to frame number
five
but before we do that let's count the
position of fifth frame in the
transmission order
one
two three four five six seven and eight
that's correct when we count the
position number for any of the frames
from the beginning we use sequence
not the sequence number given by the
question
that means fifth frame is at the
position number eight from the beginning
that means according to the question it
will get lost during the transmission
from sender to the receiver side
similarly
frame number six and frame number seven
that was sent after fifth frame will
also get discarded
according to the go back in arq protocol
again we will retransmit five six and
seven frame number to receive a site
from the sender site
after re-transmission frame number five
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side and then we can share frame number
eight from the sender to the receiver
side
and the positioning of the sliding
window shift from 567 frame to 6 7 and 8
sequence number
now let's move on to the sixth frame
but according to the positioning order
position of the sixth transmitted frame
is number 12.
that means
it will get lost during transmission
from sender to the receiver side
and similarly frame number seven and
eight will also get discarded by the
receiver side
and again applying go by nrq protocol we
will retransmit frame number 6 7 and 8.
on re-transmission frame number six will
get acknowledged by the receiver side
and we can share frame number nine from
the sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
sequence number six seven eight to seven
eight and nine
now let's recount the position of the
next frame that is frame number seven
from the beginning
and that would be
16 that means frame number seven will
get lost during transmission from the
sender to the receiver side
and similarly frame number seven eight
and nine is to be re-transmitted
according to the go back in arq protocol
now similarly following all the previous
steps we can complete this network model
using go back in RQ protocol but this is
a work you guys have to complete and
find out the total number of packets
that were transmitted from the sender to
the receiver side
and give your answers in the comment
section and the next heading is what is
selective repeat arq protocol
for the first point in selective repeat
IQ protocol we have is
the working principle
the working principle of the SRP
protocol is based on sliding window
protocol and it uses a buffer system for
storing either at the center side or the
receiver side during the data
transmission
let's move on to the next point for
Selective repeat air queue
the term arq in the protocol defines the
automatic repeat request process that is
designed to perform the task of sending
the next frame for each of the
acknowledged frame
now let's move on to the next heading
next heading is important points about
the protocol
for the first point we have is
the value of n that represents the
window size is same for both sides that
is the value of sender size is equal to
the window size of the receiver side
let's take a look at the next point
in case of selected repeat arq protocol
as the name suggests in case the frame
is not received by the receiver side or
the acknowledges not received by the
sender site as shown in the diagram
in this case the mentioned frame is to
be re-transmitted without affecting any
other frame
let's move on to the next point for this
heading
in case the frames not received by the
receiver side then it will share a
negative acknowledgment signal do the
sender side so that it can re-transmit
the damaged frame
this point forms the basis of the
working process involved in the SRP
protocol so please take a note of this
point
now let's move forward
with the working of the protocol
we'll divide the working process of the
SRP protocol in multiple steps for
better understanding let's move on for
the first step
to begin with we have a sender site and
the receiver side as usual
then we have a sequence of numbers
and our window size
now for the Second Step let's send the
First Data frame that is frame 0.
next is frame one
Frame 2 and frame 3.
these four frames Ascend for the
beginning because our window size is 4.
and a sliding window appears from
sequence number zero to sequence number
three
after the receiver side I have received
the center size frames it will
acknowledge the first frame that is
frame 0 and saying the acknowledgment
signal to the sender site
after the sender site receives the first
acknowledgment signal it will again
share the next frame in the sequence
that is frame number four
and the sliding window will shift from
frame 0 to 3 to 1 to 4.
now similarly let's acknowledge frame
number one from the receiver side to the
sender side
and the center side will share the next
frame in the sequence that is frame
number five to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
frame 1 to 4 to sequence number 2 to 5.
now
let's acknowledge frame number two
okay now let's assume that frame number
two is lost or corrupted during the
transmission
in this case if we apply go back and arq
protocol all the frames sent after frame
number two are to be retransmitted that
will be frame number two three four and
five
but
in case of SRP protocol that is
selective repeat argue protocol
only the frame that is lost during
transmission is to be retransmitted
that means
the acknowledgment signal for frame
number three will be sent from the
receiver side to the sender side
and the sender side will then
re-transmit frame number 2 to the
receiver side
this process of retransmitting only the
loss frame is known as The Selective
repeat arq protocol
and similarly we will acknowledge the
next frame that is frame number four
and send the next frame that will be
frame number six
as you can see
in this process of SRP protocol the
sliding window or the window size
clearly does not play any particular
role
with the completion of this slide we are
done with the whole working steps
involved in the SRP protocol now let's
move on to the next setting in the video
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
the next setting in this session is
difference between selected repeat L key
protocol and go back in RQ protocol
let's take a look
foreign for the first point we have
in go back and IQ protocol it does not
require a large amount of memory
as it does not provide the buffer
feature for the network model
whereas in case of selective repeat arq
protocol it requires a buffer system so
the memory needed is more on both the
sides that is a sender site and the
receiver side
now let's move on to the next point
all the frames after the loss frame in
go back and IQ protocol are to be
re-transmitted as we already discussed
in the earlier slide
whereas in case of selective repeater
protocol only the damaged or the loss
frame is to be de-transmitted
let's take a look at some other points
too
in go back in ague protocol too many
retransmission frames are required so
the efficiency of the overlr model is
very low
and in case of SRP protocol the
re-transmission frames is less
so the efficiency of the overall model
is increased
let's take a look at the last point for
the difference
the bandwidth required for go back and
IQ protocol is too high due to the more
retransmission frames
as for SRP protocol moderate bandwidth
requirement is needed
with the completion of difference
between SRP protocol and go back in our
view protocol
the user datagram protocol commonly
known as UDP protocol is designed to be
unreliable and connectionless in nature
which applies process to process
communication model for data exchange
between devices and is active with the
transport layer of the OSI model
and is used to transfer data and
information related to internet services
over the network channel where process
to process communication refers to the
use of port numbers in the header format
during the transmission of data over the
network channel
as for connectionless it means that the
UTP format does not provide established
path for the data to transfer instead it
uses multiple different paths which we
will look into further in the video
let's move on to the next heading
features of using user datagram protocol
the user datagram protocol provides the
network with various efficient and easy
to understand Network protocol features
to apply over the data that is to be
transmitted
where the first feature of UDP is
related to the working area that is the
UDP model is a transport layer protocol
of the OSI model and is used to deliver
best effort delivery options for the
data transmission where the best
delivery option refers that the protocol
does not provide the sender will receive
any acknowledgment from the receiver
site for the data transmitted or it
doesn't provide any guarantee of data
transmitted to the receiver site
now let's move on to the second feature
of user datagram protocol
the second feature represents the mode
of delivery a connection that the UDP
establishes for data transmission
the UDP protocol as we know already
establishes
a connectionless path that means there
is no actual virtual path for the data
to be transmitted
so that the each data from the UDP
format uses a random path available in
the network channel and reaches its
destination
now let's move on to the next heading
that is UTP header format
the UDP header format comprises of two
parts
first the UDP header part which is 8
bytes in size and second the data to be
transmitted
furthermore the header part is divided
into four different parts
Source Port destination Port total
length and checksum
where each of the parts are divided into
16 bits
let's take a look at the different parts
of the header format in a little detail
the first one is Source port number it
is a 16-bit value that is used to
identify the port that is transmitting
the data
next is destination port number
that is used to identify the port number
that will be receiving the data on the
receiver end
next we have total length as the name
suggests this value is used to specify
the total length of the UDP packet
including the UDP header part
and the last is checksum this is a
16-bit value field and is used as an
optional attribute
it is left empty if there is no need or
it is used in case where accuracy of the
data is to be measured
now let's move on to the working of the
UDP protocol
to begin with we have data from the
sender site
which is enclosed with a UDP header for
communication and data in the UTP header
part
the next step is to hand over this data
over to the IP section
for encapitalization
with the IP header and data with the UDP
header and data part
as for the last step this part is handed
over to the frame section where it is
transformed with the frame header and
data format
moving on now let's transmit the data
over the network channel for the
receiver and to receive it
over to the receiver side first step is
decoding of frame header part and data
part into the IP section which contains
IP header and data section
again this eyepiece packet is divided
into UDP header part and data part
from where the message is retrieved from
the data section of the UTP header
format and is then received by the
receiver end
now let's move on to the applications of
UTP protocol
let's take a look at some of the
features of the UDP protocol that
provides applications to various Network
models
for the first one we have it provides
flow control and error control mechanism
to the network model such as tftp
next it provides faster transmission of
data as there is no pre-established
virtual path needed
so it is used for real-time Services
live communication and gaming services
now let's move on to the last setting
for this session that is UDP versus TCP
protocol
we will differentiate between UDP and
TCP based on some attributes that are
mostly used in the network module and
the first attribute is reliability
for UDP protocol as we already know now
it is an unreliable in nature
that it doesn't provide any guarantee of
data transmitted to the destination site
is reached or not
as for TCP it provides reliable and
guaranteed data delivery to the receiver
site
the next attribute is acknowledgment
signal
the UDP protocol does not provide any
acknowledgment from the receiver side to
the sender site
whereas in case of TCP protocol sharing
the acknowledgment signal is very
important if the acknowledgment signal
is not shared by the receiver side to
the center side the data exchange will
halt
let's move on to the next attribute that
is connection mode
as we already know now
UDP is a connectionless mode of service
there is no virtual path established for
the data transmission to takes place
whereas for TCP protocol it is a
connection oriented protocol that is a
virtual path is needed for the data to
be transmitted over to the receiver site
or the destination node
the next attribute is error check system
in GDP protocol basic check system is
only used for error check
whereas for tcv protocol it is an
extensive error check service
and along with error flow control
mechanism included in the TCP protocol
service
let's take a look at today's agenda
firstly we will understand what exactly
the DHCP protocol is then the allocation
methods in dhcb protocol
next we will understand some helpful
DHCP settings and lastly stepwise we
will understand the operation model for
DHCP
let's understand the DHCP protocol
the dynamic host protocol or DHCP is it
protocol that is designed to assign the
IP address to a device for it to access
the internet
this network model is based on the
client server architecture and removes
the process of manually assigning an IP
address to the system
now let's take a look at the allocation
methods for the DHCP protocol
the allocation method of DHCP is divided
into two types
the first type is the manual allocation
which as the name suggests is it a
signing of IP address to the system
manually by the user
the second method is dynamic allocation
which uses a client server architecture
to assign an IP address to the system
now let's see some points regarding the
allocation method
the first type is the manual education
as mentioned in this allocation type the
user manually assigns CIP address to the
system for accessing the internet and
can be observed in this instance
this is done by accessing the network
configuration setting of the device and
also requires other related
configuration such as
subnet mask preferred DNS server and
default gateway
let's now take a look at the dynamic
allocation
in this allocation method the client
device receives all the relevant Network
configurations from the DHCP server and
the system gets configured to access the
internet
the provided IP address is given for a
certain period which is also termed as
the lease
now that we somewhat understand what
exactly the dynamic allocation in DHCP
server is let's take a look at a small
example
open the start menu
and type command prompt
when the windows open up
type
IP
config
slash
oil command
as we see by this command we can take a
look at the network settings for our
system
over here we can see that DHCP is
enabled that means the configuration
that has been used on the system refers
to the DHCP server
and on the bottom side we can take a
look at the different network settings
that are given along with the IP address
by the
DHCP server that is subnet mask
default gateway
and the DNS server
now let's continue with the video
now let's take a look at some of the
notable DHCP settings
the first one is known as scope as the
name suggests a scope refers to a range
of addresses that are available to a
DHCP server for allocation of the client
device
next we have is lease this setting of
The DHCP server is designed to prevent
the holding of IP addresses by a single
device
this is done by assigning an expiration
date to the least IP address so that the
DHCP server has a minimum addresses left
for the client device
and lastly we have address reservation
in this DHCP setting the client device
requests the server to assign the same
IP address to the device each time the
address allocation takes place
this is done by identifying the MAC
address of the client device
now let's take a look at the operation
model for DHCP protocol
the DHCP operations are performed under
user datagram protocol in short UDP
which is applied on two ports under UDP
which are ports 67 and 68.
the first phase is where the client
broadcast a DHCP server message over the
network to connect with the DHCP server
this message basically means that it
wants to connect to the internet through
the DHCP server
the second phase is when the DHCP server
receives the DHCP message
according to the message the DHCP server
reserves an IP address for the client
and network configuration information
including subnet mask default gateway
and preferred DNS server
in the third phase the client responds
to the DHCP servers offer through a DHCP
request message requesting the offer IP
address and relevant network
configuration for the system
then in the last phase the server
acknowledges the request broadcast from
the client and sends the DHCP packet to
the DHCP client which is comprised of
network configuration for the client
device to begin practicing the commands
we need to access the command prompt
application using the CMD command in the
start menu now let's begin with the list
of commands the first command is
ipconfig
this command displays the system's basic
IP address configuration data which
includes Network information about IP
addresses subnet masks and default
gateway
similarly we also have ipconfig slash
all command which displays all the
details regarding our device like Lan
settings physical address of the system
IP addresses subnet masks and DHCP
information
let's use the CLS command to clear the
application window for the next one the
next command is hostname which is used
to access the system's hostname
to verify this let's use the ipconfig
slash all command to check the hostname
in the information and for sure we have
the same hostname
let's perform the CLS command again and
perform the next command
the pin command is used to check the
communication availability of the
destination host and the user system
for example use a ping command with
google.com to check the server
availability which gives us the
following result
also using the results IP address and
then the pin command we can get the same
result in case we just don't have the
domain name
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one the nslookup
command is used to troubleshoot network
connectivity and find the IP address of
a domain like Google and Amazon as
applied just now to receive the name and
address of the domain
also using the MS lookup command and
then applying the server command with an
IP address we can get the domain name
belonging to the IP address
and similarly to check the number of
servers with the same domain name we can
do this and we have four name servers
for Google
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one
the tracered command is used to
troubleshoot the routing issues of the
network by displaying the routing table
through which the data is transmitted to
a maximum of 30 hops in the network as
you can see
similarly you can also try amazon.com
and share your views in the comment
section below
now let's clear the application window
and perform the next command which is
the ARP command this command is applied
to display the communication exchange
between the IP address and the systems
Mac or physical address
let's move on to the next command which
is the path ping command
this combines the Tracer and ping
commands and displays detailed
information as an output for a maximum
of 30 hops in the network
this command takes some time to compile
the full Hub details so that you can
share findings in the comment section
next we have the netstat command it's
used to display the network connection
summary of the system as shown in the
demo
similarly if we use the netstat hyphen n
command it will give us much more
details about the connection and UDP
details
next we have the net share command which
displays the details of where the data
resources for our system are shared and
we can check them under the share name
resources and remark column
then we have the route command that
allows us to access the routing tables
and also allows us to make changes to
them
let's try the route print command and we
have the interface list ipv4 routing
table details with all the active routes
and the IPv6 routing table moving on
let's clear the window and look at the
net sh command the netsh is a popular
command which allows us to view and
configure the network adapters in the
system
under the net sh command we have
multiple functions so configuring
settings let's try the show command and
we have the following result
moving on we have the task list command
that lists all the currently working
applications on the system with task or
program ID and the memory it uses let's
perform an example
access Google Chrome and then perform
the task list command and as expected we
have the Chrome details in the list
and if we close the Chrome window and
again use the task list command we don't
have the application active
similarly we also have the task kill
command which will terminate the task
corresponding to the given program ID in
the command window
for example let's access Chrome and
perform the task list command to check
the program ID
and then we'll use it with the task kill
command and we can see that the
application is terminated
to check our result we can access the
task list command again next on the list
we have the system info command
it's used to view all the information
about the system from the windows
version to the BIOS and booting
configuration
we can access all these details using
the system info command and the last
Network command for this session is the
wmic command
for getting detailed information on the
ports and functions of the system like
CPU details and then similarly we can
check the bio settings
let's start off with question one what
is the OSI model explain the different
layers of the OSI model OSI largely is a
theoretical model uh utilized to
understand networking and how data
packets are created and how they are
being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the TCP the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite
so OSI is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start off from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer Network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
when such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer this is the lowest layer of the
OSI model now this is where any and
every physicality of your computer comes
into the picture so it could be an uh
network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with Mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data package over the network this
is where the MAC address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer here
D diagrams are transferred from one to
another the function of this layer
routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about routing and logical
addressing IP addresses come into the
picture IP version 4 IP version 6. so
Network layer will deal with IP
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for
end-to-end connections that
automatically signifies that this is
where TCP and urep will be working
TCP stands for transmission control
protocol UDP for user datagram protocol
TCP
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas UDP is a connection ledge
protocol these two Protocols are
utilized to establish connectivity
between two machines TCP is a more
reliable method of connectivity because
there are a lot of packets that are sent
across to verify that the data has been
sent data has been received and so on so
forth whereas UDP is a connection less
protocol metatized just dumped without
verifying whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
TCP and UDP make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the session layer this
control signals between the computer it
establish maintains and terminates
connections between processes so in the
transport layer we talked about TCP and
UDP UDP being a connection less protocol
where data is just transmitted without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not whereas TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol thus
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next uh
segment of that data is being said so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgment
packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the OSI model
then comes the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mine or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for presentation encryption mechanisms
all of these work on the presentation
layer
and finally comes the application layer
where
the application itself uses a particular
protocol
so that the other machine on the
receiving end the application on that
machine would be able to understand what
the communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if I start from up top the application
layer will deal with any of the data
that the application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing a
username password all that data will be
constructed let's say to an HTTP or
https format that's where your
application layer comes into picture
then the formatting of which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer then this
transport layer and the session layer
would kick in to establish a TCP session
do the three-way handshake establish
that connectivity IP addressing would be
done on the network layer Mac addressing
would be done on the data link layer and
when everything is ready on the physical
layer the packet will be sent out at the
receiving end the packet will be
received on the physical layer and then
all these layers will be reversed and
finally at the application layer the
data would be presented to the
application who would then execute it
and showcase it on the screen of the
recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality you
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the OSI layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is Define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions are designed that way it's
basically to understand how much
conceptually you are aware about these
Technologies so you have to be very
concise don't go uh rattling about
technology too much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single ratio so one to
one right so uh one machine talking to
another machine and nobody else so also
known as point-to-point Communications
1.1 the point if you have to send
information to multiple receivers then
you will have to send it using multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into the picture so in
our case uh let's assume it's a network
where there are there's a Class C
Network approximately 255 odd machines
and Within These there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point to point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines then the multicast comes into
the picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast the third
method is known as the broadcast as it
says it is going to broadcast to all so
this is one to all that is communication
between a single user and it is going to
be sent to all the machines in that
particular Network
right so the three ways unicast is one
to one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three
what is DNS DNS stands for domain name
system it is like the internet's phone
book that is responsible for mapping the
domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in
www.google.com and then we press enter
and magically Google comes in front of
us the website rather
now how does the computer know who
Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to
our DNS servers asking what the IP
address is so in short DNS resolves
domain names to their corresponding IP
addresses
there is a DNS server which will have
this index a database of all the domains
associated with their IP addresses if
one particular DNS server does not have
that information that you're looking for
it may query another DNS server who may
have that particular response so the
first thing is when you type in domain
name it gets resolved with the DNS it
identifies the IP address corresponding
to that particular domain name and thus
allows the computer to route that packet
to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local PC you have typed in
cybersecurity.com there's a DNS
resolution that a query that goes to the
DNS server what is the IP of
cybersecurity.com the DNS server looks
it up in its particular database if it
has the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
172.17.252.1 after which the packet is
sent off to cybersecurity.com moving on
to question number four what is a
firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that I've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for right so firewall is either
a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or this allow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done based on the rules that
you have created on the firewall it will
then based on those rules identify
whether some traffic is allowed in that
Network or some traffic is to be blocked
from entering that Network so as the
screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place now there are a few
common types of firewalls that also need
to be included in the answer to this
question and the first one is a packet
filtering firewall these are the most
common types that you will come across
which analyze packets and less than pass
through only if they match an
established security rule set now here
people do get confused when we say that
we analyze packets people think that
these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct
when the definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of deep packet
inspection or a DPI as it is known if
that capability comes into the picture
you're basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
next-gen firewall okay so a packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data package for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that a connection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter Network traffic
at the application Level So when you say
application Level they work at the layer
7 of The OSI model package filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
did work on IP addressing and port
numbers will work on the network layer
of the OSI model also on the transporter
because you also look at protocols proxy
firewalls will work at layer 7 which is
the application layer of the OSI model
and will deal with application Level
protocols such as HTTP https FTP SMTP
and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do the job of the first and the second
type of firewalls
the packets are compared to loan trusted
packets but now the first question is if
there is a stateful multi-layer
inspection firewall why do we have type
1 and type 2 firewalls like packet
filtering and proxy firewalls that is
because that is how the firewalls have
evolved we started off with a packet
filtering then we added functionality to
it and so on so forth so if a question
comes what is a firewall you start off
with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN
VPN is also called a virtual private
Network it is a connection between a VPN
server and a VPN client
so it basically creates a encrypted
tunnel between the client and the VPN
server which is then utilized to secure
the connections that you're making with
the internet so as you can see in the
diagram
the user has a VPN client installed on
their machine the VPN client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the VPN
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can receive can
be received backed by the VPN server the
VPN server will encrypt that data back
and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to
eavesdrop on the communication mechanism
they will not be able to do so because
of the encrypted it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel it it is possible but
it is very difficult to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing now before we go into
advantages of distributed processing we
first have to understand what is
distributed processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems that use more than one
processor to run an application
here multiple computers across different
locations share the same processor the
advantages of Distributing processes are
as follows but before we go into the
advantages distributed computing is
basically where multiple machines will
pool their resources together to run a
singular application so an application
that has multiple resources and you can
scale up and scale down as and when
required the advantages are that it can
be very very useful in data recovery
for example read where your striping
data on various hard disks it is
reliable it is cheaper lower cost can be
achieved and it is easy to expand
because of the scalability factor that
we just talked about if there is loss of
data in one computer it can then be
recovered by another interconnected
computer and one of the examples would
be blockchain in today's world right
what is blockchain that this data is
created live and stored on a connection
of computer so if one of the computers
goes offline the other computers in that
network will still have that data and
there the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machine so instead of having a
server Bank I can have multiple machines
connect interconnected together and they
can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing mechanism
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over Internet Protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices on the
internet this protocol defines how data
should be transmitted over the Internet
by providing end-to-end Communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be established on your machine you will
need TCP
without TCP there will be no work groups
there will be no domains basically your
interconnectivity will go for a toss TCP
is a software that once installed on
your machine will then interact with the
hardware which is your network interface
cards and then your switches wires
cables and all those through protocols
that have been already pre-configured in
it So within the tcpip suite of
softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configured to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you are talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient
so the TCP model is the compressed
version of The OSI the seven layers will
get converted into four layers the
network access layer internet layer
transport layer and application layer
going on to question 8
what do you mean by ipconfig and
ifconfig both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the Internet
Protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of Microsoft Windows to view
all the adapters and the configuration
of each and every adapters for their
network interfaces so as you can see on
the right hand side in the command
prompt screen if once you type in the IP
config command on the C prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there
so you can see wireless LAN adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you will see the Wi-Fi connection
wireless LAN adapter and it can give you
the IP version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network it is on what is the default
gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on the Linux Mac or Unix operating
system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces and the configuration
of each and every interface
it is used to configure control the
tcpip network interface parameters from
the command line interface
it allows you to see the IP address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see uh the
wlp 19s
the IP address being 192 168 43.215
subnet Mass being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
192.168
43.255. question 9. what is the
difference between a domain and a work
group this can be a very interesting
question and can be a very lengthy
question at the same time a work group
is nothing but a decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine acts
in its own individual capacity
things of itself as a server right so a
decentralized network you every user
manages the resources individually on
their PC so local users on their own PCS
managing the network shares what can be
shared from that particular machine what
data should be shared should not be
shared to whom it can be shared with and
so on so forth
it is good if you got a small Network a
few machines all together uh and you
want them to interact with minimal
management effort right so each computer
each user will decide what they want to
allow other users to see on that
particular Network and all of them would
be connected over a land a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home Wi-Fi right
now that is one of the best examples of
having a work group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you've got a domain-based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are made that are to be
made Available to You whereas in a work
group your local user only meant for
that particular computer right so coming
back to the domain it is an
administrator who is going to manage the
entire domain and all of the resources
connected to the domain the resources
could be switches routers servers data
stores applications web servers Mail
Exchange servers and so on so forth so
all of these are administered by an
administrator through the domain it is
the most reliable and Optimum solution
for a large Network where multiple users
are going to interconnect and share that
data amongst each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticated and get access to
whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking section what
is data encapsulation in networking data
encapsulation refers to the process of
adding headers and trailers to the data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer will have a header and
a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the MAC address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the IP addresses port numbers
and all of those things would then be
added to this uh Traders as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication so with this we have come
to the end of this session on the
networking full course I hope this
session was informative and interesting
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources like PPT code
documents or anything then please let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happier to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here